Buổi tuần trước chúng ta vừa nói về các
cái hàm mất mát trong machining đúng
không? Chúng ta nói về các cái hàm mất
mát dành cho hai bài toán chính, bài
toán re và bài toán classification đúng
không? Đối với re vài những cái hàm loss
phổ biến ví dụ như là mean absolute
arrow này, mean square arrow này hay là
coefficient of determination đúng không?
hay người ta gọi là a square. Thế còn
đối với bài toán phân loại thì chúng ta
có cái hàm loss phổ biến là cross
entropy loss. Sau này khi chúng ta học
về bạn nào các bạn học tiếp lên khóa sau
các bạn học tiếp về deep learning chúng
ta sẽ lại gặp lại những cái hàm loss
này. Đây những cái hàm loss không chỉ
dùng cho machine truyền thống mà người
ta cũng áp dụng cho cả deep learning
nữa. Và cả sau này những cái mô hình
ngôn ngữ lớn người ta vẫn sẽ áp dụng
những cái hàm lot này. Đây những cái hàm
lót rất là quan trọng. những cái thức
nền tảng rất là quan trọng để các bạn có
thể đi sâu hơn trong EI. Đấy. Thế thì
hôm nay tuần trước chúng ta nói chúng ta
nói về các cái hàm loss rồi. Tuần này
chúng ta sẽ nói về các cái magic. Loss
với magic nó khác nhau như nào bữi trước
chúng ta nói rồi đúng không? Loss là
dùng trong quá trình huấn luyện còn
magic là dùng sau quá trình huấn luyện.
Đúng không? Lost cả Lost và magic đều
nhận đầu vào là dự đoán của mô hình và
cái giá trị thực tế đúng không? Cả Lost
và Magic. Chúng ta tính ra L hay tính ra
magic chúng ta đều phải dựa vào hai thứ.
Một là dự đoán của mô hình và hai là cái
giá trị thực tế. Nhưng mà nếu mà L chúng
ta dùng ngay trong quá trình chúng ta
đang huấn luyện mô hình thì [âm nhạc]
Magic chúng ta sẽ dùng sau khi quá trình
mô hình cái cái quá trình huấn luyện mô
hình nó đã nó đã xong rồi, nó đã kết
thúc rồi đúng không? Thế thế bây giờ sẽ
nói về các cái magic. Nói về các cái
magic. Thế thì nói về các cái magic
chúng ta sẽ nói về các cái magic của bài
toán phân loại trước, bài toán
classification trước. Thì cái trường hợp
đơn giản nhất là bài toán binary
classification, bài toán phân loại nhị
phân khi mà các bạn sẽ chỉ có hai class
thôi đúng không? Các bạn sẽ chỉ có hai
class. Ví dụ như là các bạn xây dựng cái
mô hình để phân loại xem một cái email
có phải là email spam hay là không hoặc
các bạn sử dụng cái mô hình để phân loại
xem là một cái giao dịch có phải là lừa
đảo hay không chẳng hạn. Thì đấy đều là
những cái ví dụ của bài toán phân loại
nhị phân đúng không? Thế thế bây giờ hãy
giả sử đúng không? Hãy giả sử hãy coi
như là chúng ta hãy coi như là cái mô
hình của chúng ta đã được huấn luyện
xong rồi đúng không? Hãy coi như là cái
mô hình chúng ta đã được huấn luyện xong
xuôi hết rồi. Bây giờ chúng ta chỉ có
đánh giá cái mô hình lần cuối với bộ
test để chúng ta đem đi báo cáo thôi
đúng không? Chúng ta đem đi triển khai
thực tế thôi đúng không? Thì cái mô hình
chúng ta đã huấn luyện xong rồi. Bây giờ
giả sử mình sẽ đánh giá cái mô hình này
với một cái bộ test đúng không? Ví dụ
cái bộ test các bạn nhìn thấy trên hình
đây. Bộ test đây thì mình có là mình có
bảy cái ảnh đúng không? Cái mô hình này
nó lại phân loại ảnh chó với ảnh mèo
đúng không? Input là ảnh đúng không? Và
cái output là mô hình nó chỉ ra đây đây
là con gì đúng không? Thế thì cái bộ
test này của mình đúng không? Giả sử bộ
test mình nó chỉ có bảy cái ảnh này thôi
đúng không? Còn bây giờ bảy cái ảnh này
mình đưa qua mô hình. Mô hình nó hãy đưa
dự đoán. Dự đoán của nó là cái hàm màu
đỏ này. Đây dự đoán của nó là cái hàm
màu đỏ này. Được chưa? Cái hàm màu đỏ
này nó là dự đoán của mô hình. Thế còn
cái hàm màu xanh này là cái giá trị thực
tế đúng không? Đây chính là cái label
đấy đúng không? Đây chính là cái nhãn
đấy đúng không? Thế dự đoán là cái hàng
trên.
label là cái hàng dưới. Được chưa? Thế
thế các bạn cho mình hỏi theo các bạn
bây giờ với cái hiện trạng hiện tại với
bảy cái simple như thế này, với cái dự
đoán của mô hình ở đây với cái label
thực tế đây. Thế bây giờ mình muốn đánh
giá xem là cái mô hình này của mình nó
có tốt hay không thì theo các bạn cái
magic dễ nhất mà chúng ta có thể dùng là
gì?
Đây mình muốn đánh giá xem là mô hình
mình nó có tốt hay không mình phải tính
ra một cái mình có một cái magic gì đấy
đúng không? Thế các bạn cái magic dễ
nhất các bạn có thể hình dung được là
magriic gì?
Tính phần trăm đáp án đúng trên sai.
Tính phần trăm đúng chia tổng số mới
đúng chứ không phải đúng trên sai đúng
không? Đúng rồi. Tính phần trăm tức là
tính tổng số lượng dự đoán đúng chia cho
tổng sức dự đoán đúng không? Và người ta
và người ta gọi nó là cái gì? Nó là độ
chính xác đúng không? Độ chính xác hay
là tiếng Việt mình gọi là accuracy đúng
không? Th nhìn qua nhá. Đúng không? Nhìn
qua cái đầu tiên đúng này. Cái thứ hai
sai này. Cái thứ ba sai. Cái thứ tư đúng
này. Thứ năm đúng đâ đúng không? Tức là
các bạn có bốn dự án đúng đúng không?
Các bạn có bốn dự án đúng chia tổng số
dự đoán thì có nghĩa là gì? Là cái
aquasi nó sẽ bằng là 4 chia 7 đúng
không? 4 chia 7 bằng bao nhiêu đấy? Đúng
không? Tóm lại nó bằng 4 chia 7 đúng
không? Thế acasy.
Aquac là một cái matric nó vô cùng phổ
biến cho bài toán phân loại. Nó phổ biến
cái mức mà các bạn chả cần học gì về
machining. Các bạn cũng biết cái magic
này đúng không? Thậm chí là ông bà bố mẹ
chúng ta những người chả học gì về AI
cả. Họ cũng biết về cái magic này đúng
không? Họ cũng biết về cái magic này cái
độ chính xác đúng không? Đây là cái
magic mà gần như là ai cũng biết được
đúng trẻ con nó cũng biết đúng không?
Thế magic rất là cơ bản. Máck rất là cơ
bản.
MC này ưu điểm là dễ dùng, dễ hiểu. Ờ
thế nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ có một cái vấn
đề của nó. Nó cũng sẽ có cái vấn đề của
nó.
Ví dụ đi. Ví dụ này các bạn nhìn này.
Bây giờ giả sử mình có một cái bài toán
phân loại nhị phân tổng quát nhá. Ví dụ
đây không phải phân loại chó mèo mà phân
loại ví dụ là email spam hay là không
hoặc là phân loại xem mọi người có bị
bệnh hay không. Ví dụ như vậy đúng không
chung chung? Tức là một cái bài toán
phân loại nhị phân. Theo các bạn này,
theo các bạn là với một cái bài toán mà
chúng ta chỉ có hai class thôi nhá. Với
một bài toán mà chúng ta chỉ có hai
class thôi, theo các bạn Aquac tầm trên
bao nhiêu phần trăm thì theo các bạn đấy
là mô hình tốt.
Muốn một bài toán mà các bạn chỉ có hai
class thôi thì theo các bạn là cái
aquasi nó trên bao nhiêu phần trăm thì
các bạn coi đấy là một mô hình tốt.
Trên 90 này, trên 90 này, trên 50 này,
trên 90.
Các bạn khác thì sao? Theo các bạn, với
cái cảm nhận của bạn, nếu mà tôi chỉ có
hai class thôi thì theo các bạn ờ cái
aquasi trên bao nhiêu phần trăm là tốt?
Rồi các bạn trên 50/90/ên
95/80
rồi
nhá. Ok. Có rất nhiều con số đúng không?
Thấp thì là 50, cao thì là 95 đúng
không? Bây gi các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá.
Bây giờ giả sử mình có một cái bài toán
như thế này nhá. Giờ mình có một cái bài
toán này. Bây giờ giả sử là bây giờ
bây giờ bên bên Vinm đi. Bên Vinm họ
đang liên lạc với mình, họ muốn mình
giúp họ xây dựng một cái mô hình để có
thể dự đoán, có thể phân loại xem là một
người người ta có bị người ta có bị ung
thư hay không. Được chưa? Mình họ đang
muốn mình sử dụng cái mô hình để làm sao
có thể phân loại xem mọ một người có bị
ung thư hay không. Tức là bây giờ với
cái đầu vào sẽ là một profile, một cái
hồ sơ bệnh án của một bệnh nhân và cái
đầu ra thì mình sẽ mô hình của mình sẽ
phải dự án xem là bệnh nhân này người ta
bình thường hay là người ta bị ung thư
đúng không? Đây chính là một cái ví dụ
của bài toán binary classification. Thì
các bạn chỉ có hai class thôi đúng
không? Một là class người khỏe mạnh và
hai là người class người ta bị ung thư
đúng không? Nó chỉ có hai class như vậy
thôi đúng không? Thế bây giờ các bạn ví
dụ như này nhá. Ví dụ bây giờ cứ giả sử
đi, giả sử ở Việt Nam mình đi, giả sử
Việt Nam mình trung bình cứ 100 người
nhá. Giả sử chúng mình cứ 100 người thì
có ba người bị ung thư đi. Được chưa? Cứ
100 người thì ba người ung thư và 97
người là người ta khỏe, người ta không
bị ung thư đúng không? Thế
thế bây giờ này giả sử cái mô hình của
mình nó cái mô hình machining của mình
bây giờ mình là một cái mô hình AI. Cái
mô hình mình nó rất là đơn giản thôi. Mô
hình AI của mình là gì? là bây giờ bất
kể cái hồ sơ bệnh án của bệnh nhân nó có
là gì nữa, bất kể là người này người ta
là nam hay là ngữ nam hay là nữ già hay
là trẻ giàu hay là nghèo, béo hay là
gầy, tức là bất kể cái hồ sơ người ta,
tất cả các cái chỉ số nào ấy thì cái mô
hình của mình sẽ luôn luôn phán rằng là
người ta là người khỏe mạnh. Được chưa?
Tức là cái mô hình mình nó chả học cái
gì cả. Nó chỉ đơn giản là bây giờ cứ ông
nào đi vào mô hình mình nó cũng bảo
người ta khỏe mạnh cả. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ giả sử bây giờ mình đánh giá cái
mô hình này của mình trên một cái tập
test là một cái tập có 1000 người đúng
không? Thì với mình có nói các bạn là
gì? là trung bình ở Việt Nam cứ 100
người thì sẽ có ba người người ta bị ung
thư đúng không? Thì bây giờ cái tập này
có 1000 người thì trong 1000 người này
sẽ có 30 người là bị ung thư và 970
người là người ta khỏe đúng không? Thì
bây giờ các bạn cho mình hỏi này. Bây
giờ nếu mình đánh giá cái mô hình này,
nếu mình đánh giá cái mô hình này trên
cái tập test có 1000 người kia đúng
không? Thì bây giờ nếu các bạn đánh giá
cái accuracy thì cái mô hình của mình nó
sẽ có accuracy là bao nhiêu?
Mô hình của mình nó sẽ có accuracy là
bao nhiêu?
Nào, tập test có 1000 người, trong đó có
970 người là người ta khỏe, 30 người ta
bị ung thư. Được chưa? Cái mô hình của
mình bất kể người đầu vào người ta như
nào mô hình của mình cũng bảo là người
ta bị ung thư cả à người ta khỏe mạnh cả
đúng không? Thì mô hình mình sẽ có Aquac
là bao nhiêu? 97% đúng rồi. 97% đúng
không? Nó bằng 970 chia cho 1000 đúng
không? 97% rất cao đúng không? rất cao.
Thế nếu các bạn là các bạn là chủ tịch
của VinMake, các bạn có mua cái mô hình
của mình không các bạn? Các bạn mà là
chủ tịch của Vinmx, các bạn có mua cái
mô hình của mình không?
Mua không?
Sao lại không mua? Độ độ chính xác cao
mà 97 trên cả 95 vậy các bạn bảo 95 đúng
không? Bây giờ được 97 cơ mà cao thế còn
gì nữa.
Vì sao lại không mua? Vì sao lại không
mua?
Các bạn test thôi thì cũng giống kiểu
các bạn đi thi đại học thôi, các bạn
điểm thi đạo cao là tốt rồi.
Không vì liên quan sức khỏe tính mạng
con người. Trung trung quá trung trùng
quá liên quan đến sức khỏe tính mạng
người thì làm sao?
>> Ờ theo em là bài toán này mình với bài
toán là ung thư thì mình nên a giảng một
số người mà thật sự bị ung thư nhưng mà
mình lại phán là người ta khỏe mạnh để
cho người ta có cơ hội đi khám.
Ừ cái này nó hơi sâu rồi. Tí nữa mình sẽ
cần câu trả lời này. Một tí nữa mình sẽ
cần câu trả lời này. Hiện tại mình cần
câu trả lời nó đơn giản hơn.
Vì sao trong trường hợp này 97% mà các
bạn lại không đồng ý?
>> Em nghĩ là bởi vì cái này mô hình đoán
luôn luôn đoán bừa là người đấy không bị
bệnh. Nếu mà tính theo precision thì sẽ
rất thấp.
Pron rất là thấp á.
Em nghĩ là thế
>> rồi. Có B nào có ý tưởng khác không?
Các bạn nhìn này.
Trong trường hợp này accuracy của chúng
ta là bằng 97%.
Số rất là cao đúng không? Rất là cao.
Thông thường ví dụ như bài toán phân lệ
chó mèo chẳng hạn thì 90% thì là quá tốt
luôn. Với bài toán chó mèo phân lại 97%
là quá tốt luôn. Nhưng với cái bài toán
này thì 97% nó sẽ không có nhiều ý
nghĩa. Vì sao? Vì sao trong bài toán
này, trong bài toán phân loại người bị
ung thư với người khỏe mạnh, con số 97%
nó rất cao nhưng nó lại không mang nhiều
ý nghĩa. Tại vì cái bộ dữ liệu của chúng
ta là một bộ dữ liệu nó làm sao? Nó
nó làm sao?
Không phải là không có nhãn. Trời ơi là
rời ai bảo không có nhãn. Có nhãn rồi
ơi. Rồi mất cân bằng. Đúng rồi. Cái bộ
rượu chúng ta nó dệ mất cân bằng đúng
không? Đó là imbalance. Đây là set là bộ
rượu cân bằng mất cân bằng. Thế thì cái
magic như là acasi ấ nó chỉ có ý nghĩa
nó chỉ hữu ích khi mà rượu bạn nó tương
đối cân bằng mà thôi. Còn một khi bạn nó
mất cân bằng thì aquasi nó vẫn đúng
nhưng mà nó sẽ không còn có lại nhiều ý
nghĩa. Nó sẽ không còn có tác dụng nữa.
Đúng không? Nên các bạn thấy ví dụ chúng
ta đấy đúng không? Cân mặt về mặt số
lượng. Tức là về mặt số lượng chứ còn về
mặt gì nữa? Về mặt số lượng đó đúng
không? Một class các bạn có 970, một
class các bạn chỉ có 30 thôi. Lệch đúng
không? Mất cân bằng đúng không? Mất cân
bằng về mặt số lượng đúng không? Đấy.
Thế trong trường hợp này thì nó vẫn đúng
chẳng qua là nó không hữu ích nữa thôi.
Nó vẫn đúng mà nó vẫn là 97% mà chiếu nó
không hữu ích thôi. Thế thì trong những
trường hợp mất cân bằng như vậy ấ chúng
ta sẽ cần phải có những cái magic để
chúng ta có thể đánh giá cái mô hình
chúng ta nó vừa chính xác nhưng nó lại
vừa phải hữu ích nữa. Tức là cái magic
đấy chúng ta phải nhìn vào chúng ta nói
được xem là mô hình có tốt hay không
đúng không? Chứ còn trong trường hợp dữ
mất cân bằng này. Mất cân bằng như này
đúng không? Aquos 97% các bạn nhìn vào
các bạn cũng chả nói được cái gì cả.
Được không? Thế thế thì bây giờ đối với
bài toán phân loại đâu bây gi chúng ta
sẽ nói về bài toán rượu nó mất cân bằng
đúng không? Thế thì
thông thường và các bạn nhìn này, thông
thường ấy trong thực tế khi các bạn đi
làm sau này ấ các bạn cũng rất là ít khi
mà các bạn gặp được những cái bộ dữ liệu
mà nó cân bằng. Trong thực tế các bạn
rất ít khi các bạn gặp được những cái bộ
dữ liệu mà nó cân bằng. Thông thường cái
bộ dữ liệu trong từ đấy nó thường nó sẽ
rất là lệch. Thông thường sẽ có một cái
class nó có rất nhiều sample và sẽ có
một hoặc nhiều class khác nó có rất là
ít sample đúng không? Thì đây chính là
cái ví dụ của cái dữ liệu nó
nó mất cân bằng. Nó mất cân bằng. Đây
các bạn nhìn này. Đây ví dụ đây đúng
không? Thông thường ấy cái kiểu dượu bên
trái ấ cái kiểu balance ấy các bạn sẽ
rất là ít khi các bạn gặp và các bạn sẽ
gặp kiểu unbalance hay là inbalance
dataset rất là nhiều. Một cái class
nhiều một cái class ít. Ví dụ trong ví
dụ email spam đi. Trong thực tế thì số
liệu email spam nó sẽ ít nó sẽ hư rất
rất nhiều so với email bình thường đúng
không? Hoặc là trong dịch ngân hàng
chẳng hạn đúng không? Số dược giao dịch
lừa đảo nó sẽ rất là ít so với gia dịch
bình thường đúng không? Thì trong thực
tế các bạn thấy là hầu hết các bạn phân
loại các bạn sẽ gần như các bạn ví dụ
như mình mình đi làm phong lu 10 năm rồi
mà mình chưa từng được gặp cái bài toán
nào trong thực tế mà gặp dữ liệu cân
bằng bao giờ cả. Lúc nào dữ liệu nó cũng
chỉ có là hoặc là lệch hoặc là rất lệch
mà thôi. Thì trong những trường như vậy
đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ có một cái class
là class có nhiều sample hơn người ta
gọi là class đa số và một class nó có ít
sample hơn người ta gọi là class. Đế và
thông thường ấy trong cái trưởng như vậy
ấ thông thường cái class mà chúng ta lại
muốn tập trung, chúng ta muốn chú ý hơn
ấy thông thường lại là class thiểu số.
Thế nó mới nên câu chuyện chứ còn nếu mà
cái class các bạn quan tâm hơn là class
đa số thì lại dễ rồi. Tại vì là thường
cái Aquac nó sẽ bị nghiêng về cái class
đa số. Đấy thế nên là nếu mà cái class
các bạn quan tâm là class đa số thì lại
quá dễ thôi. Nhưng mà khốn nỗi là thường
là cái dự mất cân bằng thì cái mà các
bạn quan tâm lại là cái lắp tiểu số đúng
không? Chúng ta lại quan tâm hơn về cái
lắp tiểu số. Đấy nó vấn đề. Thế trong
những trường hợp như vậy nếu mà chúng ta
dùng aquasi thì aquasi nó sẽ bị áp đảo,
nó sẽ bị quyết định phần lớn là bởi cái
class đa số. Thì như vậy lúc này mình sẽ
không còn mình không còn khả năng mình
có thể đánh giác thiểu số một cách hữu
ích nữa. Thế bây giờ mình mới phải mình
xem tìm xem là tôi có cách nào để tôi có
thể tôi
đánh giá được cái khả năng của mô hình
với cái lá tiểu số này nó nó nó có ý
nghĩa hơn. Thế bây giờ để làm được điều
như vậy thì bây giờ đầu tiên này, đầu
tiên nhá vẫn là về bài toán binary này.
Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ phải trong hai class
của chúng ta chúng ta sẽ phải chọn ra
một class mà chúng ta quan tâm hơn được
chưa? Chúng ta sẽ phải chọn ra một class
chúng ta quan tâm hơn. Thông thường cái
class mà các bạn quan tâm hơn thông
thường nó sẽ là class tiểu số nhá. Thông
thường trong hầu hết các cái trường hợp
trong thực tế thì class mà các bạn quan
tâm hơn sẽ là class. Thì cái class các
bạn sẽ gọi nó là class positive là các
bạn là cái class mà các bạn quan tâm đó.
Cái cái class còn lại các bạn sẽ gọi nó
là class negative. Được chưa? Cái class
các bạn quan tâm hơn thông thường là
class thiểu số thì nó sẽ là class
positive. Còn cái class còn lại class đa
số ấy thì chúng ta sẽ gọi nó là class
negative. Được chưa? Thế sau khi chúng
ta đã định danh tí nữa chúng ta sẽ đổi
ngược vai chưa? Tí nữa chúng ta sẽ đổi
vai trò sau không vấn đề đúng không? Bây
giờ chúng ta tạm thời chúng ta tập trung
vào cái ông các bạn quan tâm trước rồi
tí nữa tính toán xong rồi mình lại đổi
vai trò chúng mình tính toán lại từ đầu
không vấn đề gì cả. Thế thế sau khi các
bạn quyết định xem là class nào là class
positive. Class nào là class negative.
Rồi thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ bắt đầu các
bạn sẽ xây dựng nên một cái ma trận hay
là một cái bảng kích thức là 2 x2. Đây
cái bảng như này này các bạn nhìn này.
Bảng như này này. Đấy cái bảng này bảng
kí thức 2 x2 nó là một cái ma trận đúng
không? Thế cái ma trận này ấ thì cái
hàng nó có ý nghĩa là gì? Hàng nó có ý
nghĩa là những cái giá trị thực tế còn
cột nó có ý nghĩa là các cái giá trị dự
đoán đúng không? Cộng là class positive
trừ là class negative. Hàng đầu tiên là
dành cho những cái simple những cái
những cái simple mà nó nó thực sự nó là
cái class positive đúng không? Ờ cái
hàng thứ hai là những cái simple mà thực
sự nó là class negative. Thế còn cái cột
đầu tiên là cái cột dành cho những ông
nào mà được mô hình dự đoán là positive
và cột thứ hai là dành cho những cái
sample nào mà được mô hình nó dự đoán là
negative. Đấy thì mình sẽ có một cái ma
nhận 2 x2 này. Sau khi mình chọn xong
class nào class positive, class nào
class negative rồi, mình xây dựng xong
cái ma trận này rồi thì bây giờ mình sẽ
bắt đầu mình sẽ bắt đầu mình sẽ duyệt
qua các cái dự đoán của mình. Thế bây
giờ ấy mỗi một cái m dự đoán mà mô hình
nó đưa ra ấy nó sẽ rơi vào một trong bốn
trường hợp nhá. Mỗi một cái trường mỗi
một cái dự đoán của mô hình đưa ra ấy nó
lại rơi vào một trong bốn trường hợp.
Trường hợp đầu tiên đó là cái trường hợp
mà
cả dự đoán của mô hình lẫn cái label
thực tế đều là về class positive cả. Thì
ví dụ các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây đúng
không? Chúng ta có ba cái trường hợp là
cả dự đoán của mô hình với cả thực tế nó
đều là về class positive. Thế thì cái
trường hợp này thì nó sẽ gọi đây là
người ta sẽ gọi những cái người ta sẽ
gọi những cái dự án này người ta gọi nó
là true positive nhá. Tức là ở đây mình
sẽ có ba cái true positive. True. Ba cái
true positive. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái từ
này true positive ấy nó được tạo ra bởi
hai từ. Từ đầu tiên nó có thể là true
hoặc là f và từ thứ hai nó có thể là
positive hoặc là negative. Thế bây giờ
làm sao để tôi có thể xác định được từng
từ một rất là dễ thôi. Đầu tiên mình sẽ
nói về cái từ thứ hai trước. Cái từ thứ
hai ấy nó có thể là positive hoặc là
negative. Các bạn chú ý nhá. Bình thường
là nó không có s đâu. Chẳng qua đây là
số nhiều thôi. Có ba ông thì nó số nhiều
này thôi. Đúng không? Cái từ thứ hai này
ấy nó là làm sao để biết nó là positive
hay negative. Thì để xác định được cái
từ thứ hai này, các bạn chỉ cần nhìn vào
dự đoán thôi. Các bạn chỉ nhìn vào dự
đoán thôi. Nếu dự đoán là về class
positive trong trượng này, ví dụ mình là
người thích chó đi đúng không? Ví dụ
mình là người thích chó đi, mình chọn
con chó là class positive đi đúng không?
Thì bây giờ đúng không? Trong đây là ba
cái trường hợp dự đoán mà cái dự đoán
của mô hình là về class positive. Thế
nên là cái từ thứ hai này nó là
positive. Được chưa? Thế còn cái từ đầu
tiên muốn biết nó là true hay phone ấy
thì các bạn phải so sánh giữa thực tế
với dự đoán. Nếu dự đoán với thực tế nó
giống nhau thì đấy là true, còn thực tế
với dự đán nó khác nhau thì đấy là
phone. Được chưa? Nếu giống nhau thì là
true, khác nhau thì là phone. Đấy. Thì
không? Thì đây là ba cái dự đoán là về
con chó là cái lắp positive nên cái từ
thứ hai này là positive này đúng không?
Dự đoán thực tế nó giống nhau nên nó là
true thì đây người ta gọi là true
positive. Và tất nhiên là true nó là dự
án đúng rồi. Đây chúng ta có ba dự đoán.
True là ba dự án đúng đúng không? Đây là
cái loại đầu tiên. Loại đầu tiên. Cái
loại thứ hai là gì? Cái loại thứ hai là
dự đoán của mô hình là về class
positive. Thế nhưng mà dự đoán với thực
tế nó lại khác nhau. Thì các bạn nhìn
thấy này đúng không? Dự đoán là về class
positive. Thế nên là cái từ thứ hai là
từ positive này đúng không? Thế nhưng mà
dự đoán với thực tế nó lại khác nhau cho
nên đây là một dự đoán sai. Thì kết hợp
lại người ta gọi đây là fold positive
đúng không? Và phone positive là một
loại dự đoán sai. Được chưa? Vì sao là
positive? Tại vì dự đoán của mô hình là
positive. Vì sao là phone? Tại vì dự
đoán với thực tế nó khác nhau. Được
chưa? Thế cái chu à cái phone v người ta
còn có một cái tên gọi khác. Người ta
gọi đây là lỗi loại 1 nhá. Người ta gọi
đây là lỗi loại 1 đúng không? Phositive
là lỗi loại 1.
Vẫn là dự đoán sai thôi đúng không? Cái
loại tiếp theo cái loại thứ ba là gì? Là
bây giờ dự đoán của mô hình là về class
negative nhưng mà thực ra nó là class
positive. Thì cái trường hợp này nó rơi
vào cái loại là phone negative. Negative
tại vì dự đoán là về negative là con mèo
mà đúng không? Phone tại vì nó là dự
đoán sai. Được chưa? Thì đây cũng là một
loại dự án sai. Và cái loại dự án sai
này người ta có một cái tên gọi khác.
Người ta gọi đây là lỗi loại hai. Được
chưa? Lỗi loại hai đúng không? Vừa nãy
lỗi loại một, bây giờ lỗi loại hai. Được
chưa? Còn cái loại cuối cùng là gì? Là
dự đoán là về class negative. Mà đúng là
nó là class negative thật thì đây sẽ gọi
là true negative. Và tất nhiên true
negative là một loại dự đoán đúng đúng
không? Thế có nghĩa là gì? Tổng kết lại
là mỗi một cái dự đoán mà mô hình đưa ra
ấy nó sẽ chỉ có thể rơi vào một trong
hai loại này thôi. Một nó rơi vào một
trong bốn loại đúng không? Hoặc nó là
true positive hoặc nó là phone positive
hoặc nó là phone negative hoặc nó là
true negative. Nó sẽ chỉ có thể rơi vào
một bốn loại này thôi. Và tất nhiên tổng
của bốn loại này nó chính là bằng tổng
số lượng sle đúng không? Tổng của bốn
cái ông này chính bằng tổng số độ
simple. Đây các bạn nhìn này. Đây đúng
không? 3 này. Cộng 1 này cộng 2 này cộng
1 này đúng không? 07 luôn đúng không?
Đấy. Thế thế bây giờ
và cái ma trận này ấ người ta gọi đó là
confusion magic nhá. Ta gọi là confusion
magic. Confusion magic nhá. Confusion
magic. Được chưa? Thế thì bây giờ từ cái
confusion magic này người ta bắt đầu
người ta sẽ tính ra thêm những cái magic
bổ sung cho accuracy nữa đúng không? Như
mình nói đâ chu dữ liệu mất cân bằng
chúng ta dựa vào accuracy rất là khó để
biết là xem là mình có tốt hay không.
Thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ cần phải có những
cái magic mới. Được chưa? Thì cái magic
đầu tiên là gì? Cái magic đầu tiên là
precision.
Precision nó bằng cái gì? Precision các
bạn nhìn này, tử nó bằng cái này. Tử nó
bằng true positive. Được chưa? Tử của
vision là bằng true positive. Thế còn
mẫu bằng cái gì? Mẫu bằng true positive
cộng với f positive.
Được chưa?
Trong trường hợp này chúng ta đúng
không? Con chó đang là class positive
này. Con mèo là class negative đúng
không?
Thế trong trường hợp này cái có ý nghĩa
gì? Nào các bạn trong bài toán chó với
mèo này theo các bạn bây giờ tôi diễn
giải cái ý nghĩa của precision tôi diễn
giải bằng lời cho người ngoài ngành
người ta cũng hiểu thì diễn giải như thế
nào bây giờ precision đây có ý nghĩa là
gì trong trường hợp chó với mèo này nó
có ý nghĩa là gì?
Bạn nào thấy được cái cái từ pushing này
trong trường hợp chó mèo để cho người
người ta ngoài ngày người ta chả biết gì
về maching người ta cũng hiểu được
đây có ý nghĩa gì. Tử là true positive,
mẫu là true positive.
>> Theo em là nó là số dự đoán con chó đúng
trên tổng số dự đoán dự đoán liên quan
đến chó.
>> Ừ làm đi.
Đúng rồi. Tức là gì? Cái fion nó có ý
nghĩa gì? Nó sẽ có nghĩa là trong số
những dự đoán mô hình đưa ra là con chó
thì tỉ lệ chính xác là bao nhiêu?
Đúng không? Trong số những lần mô hình
đưa ra dự đoán đây là con chó thì tỉ lệ
chính xác là bao nhiêu? Đúng không? Cái
mẫu số là gì? Mẫu số là tổng số lượng
chó mà tôi à tổng số lượng con mà tôi dự
đoán là chó đúng không? Đây này. Mẫu số
là nguyên cái cột đầu tiên này đúng
không? Tổng số lần mà tôi dự đoán nó là
chó. Còn mẫu số à còn đấy là cái mẫu số
còn cái tử số là số lần chính xác đấy
đúng không? Tức là gì? Trong số những
lần đưa dự đoán đây con chó thì tỉ lệ
chính xác là bao nhiêu? Đây là ý nghĩa
của precision. Được chưa? Precision giúp
chúng ta đánh giá về mặt chất lượng của
dự đoán đối với class positive. Được
chưa? Prion giúp chúng ta đánh giá về
mặt chất lượng của dự đoán đối với class
positive.
Magic thứ hai là recolle. Recall ấy thì
cái tử nó cũng giống yệt precision. tử
dụng y hiệt nhau. Nó chỉ khác nhau cái
mẫu thôi. Nếu mà mẫu của Prision là cái
cột đầu tiên thì mẫu của recol là cái
hàng đầu tiên. Được chưa? Recode nó thể
hiện cái gì? Recode nó thể hiện là gì?
Trong số những con mà thực sự là chó ấy
thì mô hình tìm ra được tỉ lệ là bao
nhiêu. Được chưa? Trong số những con mà
thực sự nó là chó thật thì mô hình tìm
ra được bao nhiêu con?
Đúng không? Đấy là cái ý nghĩa của
recol. Nếu prion đánh giá về mặt chất
lượng thì rec đánh giá về mặt số lượng.
Quay lại ví dụ nhìn đây các bạn nhìn
nhá. Đúng không? Ví dụ trong trường hợp
này đúng không? Nói về precision đi đúng
không? Ờ
mô hình dự đoán này một con là chó này,
hai con là chó, ba con là chó, bốn con
là chó. Tức là gì? Mô hình đưa ra bốn
lần dự đoán nó là chó đúng không? Trong
bốn lần này thì có ba lần đúng, một lần
sai đúng không? Thì có nghĩa là
precision sẽ bằng 3 chia 4 là bằng 75%.
Được chưa? Thế còn recol? Rec thì thực
tế là có một con, hai con, ba con, bốn
con, năm con. Thực tế là có năm con chó.
Trong năm con chó này mô hình nó tìm ra
được ba con đúng thì rec sẽ bằng 3/5 là
bằng 60%. Được chưa? Precision đánh giá
về mặt chất lượng. Rec đánh giá về mặt
số lượng đúng không? Prion nghĩa là
trong số những con thực sự là chó thì tỉ
lệ xin lỗi presion là trong những con mà
mô hình dự đoán là chó thì tỉ lệ chúng
thực sự là chó là bao nhiêu. Còn recol
là gì? Rec là trong những con thực sự là
chó thì mô hình tìm ra được bao nhiêu
con đúng không? Prision là chất lượng.
Rec là số lượng.
Các bạn chú ý này, nói về mối quan hệ
nhá. Nói về mối quan hệ này, ở đây chúng
ta có hai cái loại lỗi là lỗi loại một
và lỗi loại hai đúng không? Trong thực
tế thì tất nhiên là chúng ta sẽ muốn là
cả hai cái này càng bé càng tốt. Thế
nhưng mà chúng ta sẽ không bao giờ chúng
ta có thể giảm được cả hai. Các bạn mà
giảm lỗi loại một thì lỗi loại hai nó sẽ
tự nhiên nó tăng và các bạn giảm lỗi
loại hai thì lỗi loại một nó cũng sẽ
tăng. Không bao giờ có thể giảm được hai
cái. Và do là cái lỗi loại 1 và lỗi lại
hai này nó chính là cái thành phần khác
nhau giữa prion với recol. Các bạn nhìn
này nhá. Precision đây, recol đây đúng
không? Chúng nó khác nhau mỗi cái thành
phần ở mẫu số thôi đúng không? Một ông
là dùng precision, một ông là dùng lỗi
loại một, một ông dùng lỗi loại hai đúng
không? Thế do là lỗi loại 1 với lỗi loại
hai ấy không bao giờ cùng giảm được. Thế
nên là prion với recolle ấy, pression
với recol cũng giống như là aquasi càng
gần một thì càng tốt, càng gần không thì
càng tồi. Thế nhưng mà prion với recolle
ấy chúng ta cũng sẽ không bao giờ chúng
ta có thể cùng tăng được.
Prin vi rec chúng ta cũng sẽ không bao
gi chúng ta cùng năng được cứ một ông
tăng thì ông kia sẽ giảm được chưa?
Precident recall các bạn sẽ không bao
giờ các bạn cùng tăng được. Cứ một ông
tăng là ông kia sẽ giảm tại vì chúng nó
liên quan đến lỗi lại một với lỗi lại
hai đúng không?
Prision thì là chất lượng, recall thì là
số lượng. Cũng giống như các bạn kinh
doanh thế thôi. Các bạn mở quán ăn nhá
các bạn chỉ có một quán thôi, các bạn sẽ
lo nó rất là chỉnh chu, rất là tốt thì
các bạn sẽ có các bạn sẽ có chất lượng
rất là tốt đúng không? Nhưng việc các
bạn muốn mở rộng ra thì nhiều quán ăn
chẳng hạn thì tên các bạn sẽ tăng cái số
lượng lên nhưng mà chất lượng nó sẽ giảm
đi đúng không? chất lượng và số lượng
thì không bao giờ cùng tăng với nhau cả.
Thì prent với rec nó cũng như thế đúng
không? Không bao giờ hai con này cùng
tăng được. Được chưa? Đấy là về prent về
recolle.
Thì ngoài ra người ta có một cái magic
nữa người ta được gọi là magic này gọi
là trung bình điều hòa cho prion recol.
Người ta gọi là F1 score. F1 score thì
nó bằng hai lần tích của prent c chia
cho tổng của chúng nhá. Hai lần tích của
prent c chia cho tổng của chúng. Cái
magic này đ là trung bình điều hòa.
Trung bình điều hòa. Trung bình điều hòa
được chưa? Trung bình điều hòa. Thế tổng
kết lại là chúng ta sẽ có bốn cái magic
như này. Được chưa? Tổng lại chúng ta sẽ
có bốn cái magic như này. Được chưa?
Accuracy thì ai cũng biết rồi. Được
chưa? Pression record one. Với accuracy
thì nó không phân biệt là ông nào là
class positive, ông nào là class
negative, nó không phân biệt. Nhưng mà
rec f1 thì nó sẽ phân biệt. Các bạn chọn
con chó là class positive thì nó sẽ có
cái prion recon của class con chó. Các
bạn chọn con mèo là class positive thì
nó sẽ có cái prion conv của class con
mèo. Đấy, còn aquasi thì ông nào là là
positive không quan trọng. Aquas nó luôn
luôn chỉ có một giá trị thôi. Được chưa?
Thì đây là những cái magic dành cho bài
toán phân loại. Aquasi người ta sẽ dùng
trong trường hợp dữ liệu cân bằng. Thế
nhưng mà trong thực tế thì các bạn chả
bao gi có dữ liệu cân bằng đâu. Còn
prion recol về F1 là dùng trong trường
hợp mà dữ liệu của các bạn nó mất cân
bằng đúng không? Imbalance đúng không?
Và thông thường người ta sẽ hay quan tâm
hơn đến rec F1 của cái class. Tức là các
bạn chọn class positive đấy đúng không?
Thông thường ấy trong những cái bài báo
mà người ta những cái bài báo nghiên
cứu, bài báo khoa học ấy người ta rất
hay người ta thích sử dụng F1 Score với
bài toán phân loại ấ người ta rất hay
thích sử dụng F1 Score tại vì nghe nó có
bài tổng quát tại vì F1 Score là nó tổng
hợp giữa recol. Thế nhưng mà trong những
cái bài toán thực tế thì các bạn sẽ phải
quyết định xem là là các bạn sẽ phải
quyết định xem là
là với cái bài toán này thì các bạn sẽ
với mỗi bài mỗi cái một cái bài toán
khác nhau các bạn sẽ quyết định xem là
cái bài toán này của bạn các bạn cần số
lượng hay là các bạn cần chất lượng. Các
bạn cần tập trung vào tối đa được prion
hay các bạn tập trung tối đa vào recol
đúng không? Trong b toán thực tế các bạn
phải quyết định được xem là tôi cần cái
gì thì lúc đấy các bạn mới có cái hướng
để các bạn tối ưu nó đúng không? Thông
thường các bạn sẽ phải quyết định xem là
cần cái gì vision hoặc recall cùng cực
bất đắc dĩ lắm mà các bạn không phân
biệt nổi là cái bài toán này các bạn cần
nghĩ gì thì lúc đấy các bạn mới dùng đến
F1 score. Đấy nhưng mà rất rất hạn hữu
thôi các bạn mới dùng đến F1 score. Tức
là gần như là phương án cuối cùng khi
các bạn không phân biệt nổi vậy mới dùng
F1 được chưa? Thế nhưng mà khi trong môi
trường hàn lâm nghiên cứu người ta lại
hay thích dùng F1 tại vì nghe nó có vẻ
tổng quát đúng không? F1 là bao gồm cả
prion và recol trong công thức này. P là
prion S R là recol này. Được chưa?
Rồi có bạn nào câu hỏi gì về các cái
matric này không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì về các cái
>> Dạ anh ơi cho em hỏi.
>> Ừ
>> à ở ở em hỏi ở cái bài trước cái bài
toán liên quan đến reaction ấy anh thì
mình có hai cái mình có hai cái matric
đó là mae và mse.
>> Ờ
>> thì cái tên gọi hình như là một cái tên
gọi khác của MAE là L1 còn MSE là L2
đúng không anh? Ờ đúng rồi ta cũng phải
gọi đúng rồi. Chính xác chính xác chính
xác tại em hay bị nhầm cái L1, L2 với
lại cái cái cái R1 như anh vừa nói á.
>> Cái này đây là
ý em là cái rec là cái gì? F1 score. Dạ
đúng rồi. Em ý em là cái F1 này
>> em phải nhầm cái L1 L2 với lại cái F1 nó
hay bị nó cùng với số 1 đ không? Đây là
F1 score.
>> One ở đây thể hiện cái gì? One ở đây thể
hiện là tỉ lệ giữa pion recolle là 1
chia 1. Người ta còn có cái magic là
f0,5 với cả f2 nữa. Nhưng mà f0,5 với f2
tức là một trong hai ông này sẽ t nhiều
hơn. Nhưng mà thời gian m f0,5 f2 cũng
không cần thiết. Tại vì là biết ông nào
cần hơn thì tôi sẽ dùng fision về recể
gì tôi phải khổ. Tôi dùng f1 làm cái gì
cả.
Rồi
đây prent đây rec đây. Một ông thì sử
dụng lỗi loại một, một ông sử dụng lỗi
loại hai mà hai cái này thì không bao
giờ cùng giảm được đúng không? Một cái
là chất lượng, một cái là số lượng. Làm
sao chất lượng số lượng cùng tăng được
các bạn đúng không? Làm sao chất lượng
với số lượng cùng tăng được?
Dễ hiểu m đúng không? Hả?
>> Về mặt công thức thì em cũng cũng nói
chung là cũng hiểu nhưng mà em đang chưa
hiểu cái ý mà số lượng và chất lượng ý
nghĩa là theo em hiểu thì tức số lượng
tăng thì gọi là chất lượng tăng. Em đang
hiểu như thế bị khó nhớ
>> lượ số lượng chất lượng không thể cùng
tăng được. Vô lý các bạn nhìn thấy số
lượng chất lượng có nghĩa gì? Chất lượng
tên này. Chất lượng tức là một khi tôi
đưa ra dự đoán thì dự đoán đó nó phải
đúng. Đấy là chất lượng. Thế còn số
lượng là gì? Số lượng là trong thực tế
tôi có từng đấy cái sle thuộc về class
đấy thì tôi tìm ra được bao nhiêu chất
lượng trong chợ này có nghĩa gì? Tức là
chất lượng có nghĩa là mỗi khi các bạn
đưa dự đoán là con chó thì dựa đấy nó
phải chính xác thì đấy là chất lượng.
Thế còn số lượng là gì? Số lượng là
trong thực tế có n con chó thì tôi tìm
ra được bao nhiêu con? Ừ. Chất lượng số
lượng không bao giờ đi cùng với nhau.
Ngoài đời nó cũng thế đúng không?
Các bạn sẽ không thể nào các bạn tìm
được một cái nhà hàng nào người ta có
thể tối ưu được cả hai cái đâu. Chất
lượng mà tốt ý tức là các bạn có ít quán
thôi. Còn một khi các bạn mở rộng ra thì
nhiều quán các bạn nhượng quyền rồi thì
chất lượng nó sẽ đi xuống là điều hiển
nhiên.
Dạ anh ơi.
>> Ừ.
Cái chất lượng thì em hiểu ví dụ trong
cái trường hợp của mình là mình dự đoán
chó tổng cộng là 1 2 3 4 lần
>> ừ
>> nhưng mà chỉ có ba lần mình đúng thôi.
Tức là cái re của mình sẽ là 3 phần 3 ph
>> 3/4 cộng 3 là 7 3/7
>> sợ 3/7 đâu 3/7
>> ơ ờ
>> 3/4
>> à 3/4 đúng rồi 3/4 là 0,75 ờ
>> em hiểu cái đấy nhưng mà em chưa hiểu
cái số lượng anh ví dụ ở đây cái số
lượng là đúng
>> số lượng không số lượng là gì trong thực
tế còn năm con chó
>> dạ
>> thì mô hình tìm ra được bao nhiêu con
>> mô hình tìm được ba Con
>> đúng rồi. Thì là recol là bằng 3/5 là
bằng 60% đấy.
>> Đấy là số lượng
>> à rồi anh hiệu anh.
>> Ờ đúng không? Chất lượng số lượng không
bao giờ đi cùng với nhau đúng không? Tí
nữa mình cho tí mình cho các bạn một vài
ví dụ các bạn sẽ thấy là vì sao hai này
không bao giờ đi cùng với nhau nhá.
Nhưng mà ngoài đời các bạn thấy thôi
đúng không? Ngoài đời chẳng bao giờ có
gì chất lượng lực sự đi cùng với nhau
đâu rồi ạ. Không bao giờ có cái gì hai
cái đi cùng nhau đâu đúng không? Đi cùng
nhau được thì lại perfect quá đúng
không?
Rồi trước khi mình vào một vài những câu
hỏi để xem các bạn hiểu hai này đúng
không nào thì có bạn nào các bạn thắc
mắc gì về cái định nghĩa của pion với
recolle không?
Có bạn nào thắc mắc gì với nghĩa của
pion với recol không?
Nhớ nhá. Prisan
>> thế hỏi đi nà. B hỏi đ hỏ này thì cái
precision với l đấy thầy thì thầy theo
thầy nó có liên quan gì đến với độ nhạy
độ đặc hiệu không thầy? Độ nhạy gì ạ?
>> Độ nhạy và độ đặc hiệu đi.
>> Ờ từ tiếng Anh là gì? Mình th tiếng Việt
mình cũng không nhớ nhiều từ lắm đâu. Từ
từ mà có từ tiếng Anh không ạ? Cái à cái
sensitivity với cả cái cái cái gì có có
nó có liên quan nó là cái tên có một cái
nó là tên ngoại khác. Tí nữa mình sẽ nói
đến phần đấy nhá.
Rồi thì các bạn nhá, mình nhắc lại này,
với các cái bài báo nghiên cứu ấ người
ta với bài toán phân loại người ta rất
hay thích dùng F1 tại vì là F1 thì nó
bao trùm cả và cả recol ở bên trong.
Nhưng mà khi mà các bạn đi làm các bài
toán thực tế thì các bạn sẽ phải chọn
một trong hai cái. Chọn một trong hai
cái các bạn tập trung vào
phải xem là các bạn các bạn muốn tập
trung vào pion hay là tập trung vào
recall. Nó chỉ một trong hai cái thôi
đúng không? Tập trung vào cái này thì
cái kia nó sẽ bị giảm. Tập trung vào cái
kia cái này sẽ bị giảm. Không bao giờ
cũng thế.
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Thế và các bạn phải biết các bạn tập
trung vào cái gì các bạn mới biết là các
bạn sẽ làm sao để các bạn tối ưu cái
đấy. Tại vì một cái liên quan đến chất
lượng, một cái liên quan đến số lượng
giống kiểu các bạn mở quán thế thôi.
Muốn chất lượng thì mở ít quán thôi, còn
muốn số lượng muốn số lượng thì mở nhiều
quán lên đúng không? Thế
thì thế bây giờ mình cho các bạn một vài
ví dụ nhá. Mình cho các bạn một vài ví
dụ để các bạn thấy xem là một m bài toán
các bạn cần cái gì. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ nhá, bài toán đầu tiên này. Bài toán
đầu tiên nhá. Thế bây giờ [hắng giọng]
giả sử đi giả sử đi mình đang mình đang
mình đang mình đang tám một bạn nữ đi
được không? Mình rủ được bài đấy là tối
nay 8:00 dạy xong cái lớp data machining
21 này mình rủ bài đi ăn được chưa? Mình
rủ bài đi ăn thế đúng không? Thì bây giờ
cái công việc của mình là gì? Là dạy cho
các bạn xong rồi mình phải tìm một quán
để mình rủ bạn ấy đi ăn đúng không? Mình
phải tìm một cái quán ăn. Thế bây giờ
quán ăn tất nhiên là mời thì mình phải
tìm một quán ăn ngon rồi đúng không? Thế
bây gi mình sẽ coi như là bây giờ ở cái
hai thành phố Hà Nội này quán ăn nó chỉ
có hai loại thôi. Được chưa? Nó chỉ có
hai loại thôi. Một là quán ngon và hai
là quán không ngon. Được chưa? Một là
quán ngon và hai là quán không ngon. Tất
nhiên là số lượng quán ngon nó sẽ ít hơn
quán không ngon rồi đúng không? Quán
ngon nó sẽ ít hơn quán không ngon rất
nhiều đúng không? Thế bây giờ cái bài
toán chúng ta nó chính là bài toán phân
loại nhị phân đúng không? Chính là bài
toán binary classification. Chúng ta chỉ
có hai class thôi đúng không? Class ngon
là class thiểu số. Class không ngon là
class đa số. Và tất nhiên là bây giờ
chúng ta sẽ muốn tập trung vào class
đúng không? Thế bây giờ nhiệm vụ của
mình là gì? Là bây giờ mình muốn lên một
cái shortlist. Mình muốn lên một cái một
cái shortlist gồm những cái quán ăn ngon
ở Hà Nội để đến cuối cùng mình sẽ chọn
ra một cái quán trong cái shortlist này
để mình mời bạn nữ kia đi ăn. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ các bạn cho mình hỏi này.
Bây giờ theo các bạn bây giờ khi mình
lên cái shortlist này như mình nói rồi,
cái class ngon là class thiểu số, là
class positive đúng không? Class không
ngon là class đa số là class negative.
Thì các bạn cho mình hỏi này, khi mà
mình lên cái shortlist gồm những quán ăn
ngon ở Hà Nội này để đến cuối tí nữa
mình chọn một quán ấy thì theo các bạn
khi mình lên shortlist này theo các bạn
mình nên tập trung tối ưu precision hay
mình nên tập trung tối ưu vào recall và
lý do là vì sao?
Lý do là vì sao?
>> Quán ngon là positive còn quán không
ngon là negative đúng không anh?
>> Đúng rồi. Thông thường bao giờ quán
thiểu số cũng là positive là thứ nó quan
tâm hơn. Còn cái quán đa số là các
negative. Thông thường không ạ? là lên
tối ưu theo chất liệu là precision.
>> Nào theo các bạn là khi mình lên list
này mình nên mình nên tối ưu vào vision
hay mình nên tối ưu vào recol bây giờ?
>> Theo em là sẽ tối ưu vào recall tại vì
là trong số những quán thật sự ngon
ngoài kia thì anh tìm được bao nhiêu
quán ngon? Chính xác anh tìm được bao
nhiêu quán ngon thì cái đó mới là cái
quan trọng.
>> Ừ.
Nào
vision hay nhỉ?
>> Nghĩ là tìm được mà chắc chắn đúng thì
nó sẽ lên được ưu tiên hơn. Em nghĩ là
precision
>> precision
khác thì sao
nào? Hầu hết các bạn đều bảo là
precision.
Đấy là precision tức các bạn muốn tập
trung vào chất lượng.
Có bạn nào có bạn giải thích cho mình là
ờ mình vẫn muốn nghe giải thích nữa.
Theo các bạn là vì vì sao tôi tập trung
vào prion tôi không tập trung vào rec.
Tập trung vào rec thì làm sao? Tập trung
rec thì làm sao?
Nếu tập trung vào recol có nghĩa là mình
muốn cái gì các bạn? Tập trung vào
recall có nghĩa là mình muốn tìm
a Long Hoàng máy giải thích hay này.
Long Hoàng giải thích hay này. Không cần
tìm nhiều quán ngon mà càng tốt mà chỉ
cần một quán ngon mà quán đấy bắt đán
không đúng không? Mà chỉ cần là ăn một
quán mà nó chắc lắm phải ngon đúng
không? Không ngon thì em kia mới bỏ.
Đúng rồi các bạn nhìn này nhá. Các bạn
nhìn này nhá. Bây giờ đúng không? Nếu
mình tập trung vào recol, tập trung vào
recol có nghĩa là mình muốn là phải tìm
ra được càng nhiều quán ăn ngon thì càng
tốt đúng không? Các bạn cho mình hỏi
này, bây giờ ấy mình muốn có cái recol
thật là cao ấy thì theo các bạn cách dễ
nhất là chúng ta làm như nào? Bây giờ
giả sử mình có danh sách của 10.000 quán
ăn ở Hà Nội nhá. 10.000 quán ăn ở Hà Nội
là bao gồm cả ngon cả không ngon đúng
không? Mình có danh sách rồi 10.000 quán
rồi. Bây giờ ấy mình muốn có cái rec nó
cao thì cách dễ nhất là mình làm thế nào
các bạn?
Cách dễ nhất là mình làm như nào?
Không đây dư nhiên đánh giá khách hàng
không phải đúng rồi cách dĩ nhất là gì
là bốc cả 10.000 quán vào đúng không tôi
bảo là cả 10000 quán này đều ngon thì
lập tức là rec sẽ bằng 100% đúng không
tại vì trong 10.000 quán này có một vài
quán ngon thì nó cũng nằm trong đấy hết
rồi đúng không? Thì bây giờ các bạn bảo
cả 10.000 quán đều ngon thì tức là
record là 100% ngay đúng không? Nhưng mà
các bạn cứ thừng nghĩ mà xem đúng không?
Đến cuối thì mình cũng chỉ được chọn có
một quán thôi đúng không? Bây giờ lên
cái list này tôi cũng chỉ được chọn một
quán thôi đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi
cho hết vào như vậy thì tôi bốc ra một
quán đấy thì cái tỉ lệ tôi bốc sii nó sẽ
cao đúng không? Thì bây giờ thay vì tập
trung vào recall tôi tập trung vào
precision. Tập trung vào precision có
nghĩa gì? Tức là có thể ở Hà Nội nó có
khoảng 100 quán ngon nhưng mà tôi có thể
tôi bỏ lỡ một vài quán tôi có thể bỏ lỡ
phần lớn quán trong đấy cũng chả sao cả.
Tôi chỉ cho vào cái shp tôi chỉ có năm
quán thôi đúng không? Tức là tôi có thể
tôi bỏ lỡ chín mấy quán ngon. Thế nhưng
mà một khi quán nào mà tôi đã cho vào
cái list này rồi thì quán đấy nó nhất
định là nó phải thực sự là ngon đúng
không? Tôi có thể tôi bỏ lỡ rất nhiều
quán ngon. Thế nhưng mà cái quán năm mà
tôi cho vào đây ấ là thực sự nó phải
ngon thật đúng không? Nó phải khách sạn
năm sao, nó phải là Micheline ba sao
đúng không? Nó phải thực sự ngon đúng
không? Tại vì đến cuối là tôi cũng chỉ
được chọn ra một quán thôi mà đúng
không? Đến cuối chọn bạn kia mời bạn kia
cũng chỉ mời đơn một quán thôi mà chắc
gì đã còn lần sau nữa đúng không? Chắc
gì đã còn lần sau nữa mà chọn click dài
làm cái gì đúng không? Chọn một list
ngắn thôi đúng không? Có thể là khả năng
lần đầu cũng là lần cuối luôn đúng
không? Đấy trong trường hợp này chúng ta
sẽ cần tập trung vào precision đúng
không? Trong cái solid ít quán thôi, năm
quán, ba quán thôi cũng được đúng không?
Nhưng mà quán nào các bạn cho vào là
phải ngon đúng không? Chấp nhận là việc
các bạn sẽ bỏ lỡ rất nhiều những quán
khác đúng không? Vision cao, recol có
thể rất là thấp tại vì các bạn tìm được
rất là ít quán nhưng mà một khi các bạn
chọn trong cái list đấy thì nó phải là
cái quán thực sự chất lượng đúng không?
Thì trong trường hợp này các bạn sẽ cần
vào cần gì? Cần precision đúng không?
appreciation. Đấy, đấy là một ví dụ. Ví
dụ đúng không? Thế bây giờ ví dụ thứ hai
nhá. Ví dụ thứ hai này. Thì bây giờ ờ
quay về cái thời kỳ mà Việt Nam mình còn
đang oản mình chống dịch Covid đi đúng
không? 2020 2021 đúng không? Thì cái hồi
Covid á đúng không? Thế bây giờ nhà nước
muốn xây dựng cái mô hình để có thể dự
đoán xem một người ta có bị Covid hay
không đúng không? Thì chúng ta lại có
hai class đúng không? Class thiểu số là
class bị Covid, class đa số là class
khỏe mạnh đúng không? Thì tất nhiên là
chúng ta sẽ phải tập trung vào class
thiểu số rồi đúng không? Thế bây giờ nếu
chúng ta sử dụng cái mô hình để phân
loại xem mọi người ta có bị Covid hay
không đúng không? Ờ nó chỉ có hai đầu ra
thôi, bị và không đúng không? Bị Covid
là positive là thiểu số, không bị là
negative là đa số. Thì bây giờ các bạn
theo các bạn là bây giờ cái mô hình này
của mình theo các bạn nó phải tập trung
vào hay nó tập trung vào rec
nào? Pression hay là hay là recall?
Các bạn thử nhớ cái hồi cái hồi dịch đi.
Lúc đầu thì precision, sau thì recol.
Cái hồi đầu ấy, cái hồi đầu cái lúc mà
nước mình nó còn ít người bị ấ cái lúc
mà vẫn còn đếm là bệnh nhân thứ nhất,
bệnh nhân thứ hai, bệnh nhân thứ ba ấy,
cái hồi mà chúng ta ít người bị ý các
bạn nhớ rồi đấy chúng ta chúng ta chúng
ta bắt người kiểu gì không các bạn? Cái
hồi mà rất là ít ý còn đếm là bệnh nhân
số một, bệnh nhân số hai, bệnh nhân số
ba ấy đúng không? Hồi đấy chúng ta chúng
ta tìm người bị bệnh người ta chúng ta
tìm kiểu gì các bạn? À đúng rồi, lụm
đúng không? tiếp xúc ở lụm. Đúng rồi,
đúng rồi. Mình nhớ thấy có cái bạn du
học sinh ở Anh về đúng không? Vù về cái
chỗ trúc bạch ở chỗ đối diện hồ tây ấ
đúng không? Và về đấy là xong cả khu là
bị phong tỏa luôn đúng không? Bao nhiêu
người cho vào tức là gì? Cái hồi ban đầu
ấy đúng không? Chúng ta muốn là gì? Tìm
được càng nhiều người bị Covid càng tốt
đúng không? Muốn tìm bắt nhầm còn hơn bỏ
sót đúng không? Và cách làm gì? Là không
chỉ F0 mà chúng ta chơi cả F1, F2, F3,
F4 thô có khi là ông nào chỉ hít không
khí ở đấy thôi là cũng bị đúng không?
Mình nhớ là hồi đấy mình đang ở Đức mình
nghe thấy là có một cái mẹ mình kể một
cái vụ là có một bạn shipper bạn ấy ship
đồ sang chỗ Khâm Thiên ở Hà Nội ấy. Khâm
Thiên ở Hà Nội bà ấy lúc ấy đi ship vào,
bà ấy vừa mới vào đấy khu đấy xong thì
cả cái con phố ấy nó bị nó bị phong tỏa
luôn. Thế là ship vào được có mấy chục
đồng thôi. Thế là so với phong tỏa bãy
phải thuê phòng đấy mất phong tỏa hết
một hai tuần hết mấy triệu thuê nhà ở
đấy. Đấy tức là hồi đấy chúng ta bắt là
kiểu lúc là kiểu bắt nhầm còn hơn bỏ sót
đúng không? Không không cho ai thoát ra
cả đúng không? Bắt thả bắt 100 người
nhầm còn hơn là để sót lò mất một người
đúng không? Thế tức là với vị này chúng
ta lại cần chúng ta cần gì? Chúng ta cần
recall đúng không? Ít nhất là cái hồi
đầu dịch đúng không? Hồi đầu dịch chúng
ta cần recall. Recall có nghĩa là F0,
F1, F2, F3, F4, F mấy bắt cho bằng sạch
đúng không? Bắt cho bằng sạch. Đấy, sau
dịch à đến lúc mà nhiều người thì mình
thôi đâ chúng ta không nói nữa đúng
không? Lúc đấy thì mình cũng không rõ
lắm nhưng mà tóm lại cái hồi đầu dịch
đúng không? lúc mà chúng ta cũng còn đếm
cái đồ đấy mình nhớ là ở ở Đức ấy nó nó
chết nhiều như ngả dạ rồi mà Việt Nam
mình vẫn cứ đếm 1 2 3 4 thôi mình đang
vẫn tập đếm chưa đến số 10 bên kia nó
mới chết mấy chục nghìn người rồi đấy
đúng không chúng ta hồi đây hồi đầu dịch
chúng ta trống rất là tốt đúng không
chúng ta chống theo tiêu chí là bắt nhầm
con bỏ só các không trong rất nhiều
trường hợp thấy không số lượng người ta
lại ưu tiên hơn chất lượng đúng không
nghe thì có vẻ chất lượng là cái thứ gì
nó rất là premium thế nhưng mà không
phải như vậy có những lúc người ta lại
cần số lượng hơn đúng không cần số lượng
hơn thế đấy là hai ví dụ đúng không Một
ví dụ tôi cần chất lượng, một ví dụ tôi
cần số lượng. Đúng không?
Rồi có bào có câu hỏi gì không?
>> Hả?
>> Mình có thể tư duy kiểu kiểu là mình
muốn giảm kiểu với FN hay là FP được
không? Tại vì c nghĩ việc là
>> được chứ
>> tăng chất lượng hay là tăng số lượng nó
sẽ hơi khó.
Với mình, với mình thì mình thấy là nói
chất lượng số lượng nó sẽ dễ nhớ hơn là
lỗi lại một, lỗi lại hai. Tại vì hai cái
lỗi e nó chỉ khác nhau cái số thôi. Còn
chất lượng với số lượng thì chúng ta
nhưng mà ok không sao các bạn hiểu kiểu
gì cũng được. Tại vì là một ông thì đi
kèm với lỗi loại một, một ông thì đi kèm
với lỗi loại hai. Các bạn hiểu kiểu gì
cũng được. Trong số những cái câu hỏi
phỏng vấn về maching ấy có những cái bộ
câu hỏi rất là phổ biến là câu hỏi phân
biệt giữa A với B.
Phân biệt giữa prion với cả recol, phân
biệt giữa lốt lại 1 với lốt lại 2. Rồi
phần sau các bạn sẽ học là phân biệt
giữa bias với cả variant. Rồi phân biệt
giữa L1 với cả L2 rồi phân biệt rất
nhiều cái cặp giữa A với B. Đấy rồi
chúng ta học về mô hình chúng ta sẽ học
về phân biệt giữa linear với cả logistic
reaction. Đấy nó sẽ có cặp như vậy. Thì
cái cặp phân biệt giữa magic pion
vericle hay là phân biệt giữa L 1 L 2 là
một cái cô này rất là phổ biến. Và như
kinh nghiệm của mình ngày xưa ấy đi
phỏng vấn người ta hay có kiểu gài.
Người ta hay gài. Tức là gì? Đầu tiên
người ta sẽ hỏi là để đánh giá một cái
mô hình classification chúng ta sẽ dùng
cái gì đúng không? Thì mình sẽ nói là
dùng dùng accuracy đúng không? Sau người
ta sẽ hỏi đấy cái đúng câu với mình hỏi
các bạn ấy là accuracy mà một bài toán
phân loại nhị phân thì acasi bao nhiêu
phần trăm trở nên là tốt? Thì các bạn
bất kể các bạn kể một cái con số nào đấy
thì đấy cũng là câu trả lời sai đúng
không? Với câu hỏi là accuracy của bài
toán phân loại nhị phân bao một tà phân
loại trung chung thôi bao nhiêu trở lên
là tốt? Các bạn trả lấy con số bao nhiêu
cũng là sai, 99% cũng là sai. Tại vì
người ta sẽ tìm ra cái trường hợp nó còn
hiếm hơn nữa. T ví dụ là 1000 sample nó
chỉ có một sample th các đấy thôi đúng
không? Các bạn sẽ phải trả lời là nó còn
tùy nó tùy vào cái bộ dữ liệu đúng
không? Xong người ta sẽ hỏi bạn nói cụ
thể hơn. Xong các bạn bảo là với bộ dữ
liệu mà mất cân bằng thì sẽ không dùng
accuracy được. Rồi bắt đầu sẽ tòi ra là
prion recol. Sau người ta sẽ lại hỏi một
cái câu hỏi bệnh nữa là gì? Là tôi phải
làm thế nào để tôi có thể tăng được cả
prent recolle. Các bạn ngồi các bạn trả
lời bất kỳ một cái gì ấ thì nó cũng là
sai đúng không? Pression recol về mặt tự
nhiên là không bao giờ có thể tăng cả
hai được.
Khi [khịt mũi] nào dùng F1? F1 là khi
các bạn làm những cái bài bóng nghiên
cứu khoa học thì các bạn dùng F1 tại vì
F1 nó tổng quát. Thứ hai là trong bài
toán thực tế mà nếu các bạn không thể
nào các bạn phân biệt nổi là các bạn cần
cái gì hơn thì đây các bạn dùng F1
rồi. Có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Nhớ nhá. Trong đi làm thực tế bao giờ
các bạn có phải ưu tiên là xem là cái
bài toán này các bạn xem là bài toán này
cần cái gì? Cần Pion H trước. Đừng đừng
có chăm vào F1. F1 nó chỉ được cái nào
nó tổng quát thôi. Nhưng mà nếu các bạn
tập trung vào F1 các bạn sẽ không biết
là các bạn phải ưu tiên cái gì. Tại vì
F1 các bạn nhìn thấy này các bạn nhìn
công thức của F1 này đây đúng không? Hai
ông bình đẳng với nhau đúng không? Hai
ông bình đẳng với nhau thì làm sao mà
các bạn dựa vào các bạn biết là các bạn
cần tập trung vào cái gì bây giờ đúng
không? Nó chỉ đẹp về mặt số liệu nhưng
mà rất là các bạn không thể dựa nó các
bạn biết là các bạn tập trung vào cái gì
được đúng không? Muốn biết tập trung vào
cái gì thì phải dựa vào Vision verical
bạn nhá. Thế bây giờ giả sử đi bây giờ
mà các bạn khi mà các bạn biết là các
bạn muốn tập trung vào cái gì rồi các
bạn sẽ rất là dễ các bạn các bạn để các
bạn có thể điều chỉnh các bạn có thể tối
ưu được cái đấy. Ví dụ nhá với cái bài
toán sự phát hiện người bị Covid vừa rồi
đúng không? Bây giờ mình muốn tăng rec
mình phải làm thế nào? Bây giờ ấy với
bài toán phát hiện người bị Covid ấ tôi
muốn tăng recol tôi làm thế nào?
Tôi làm thế nào? Tôi muốn tăng recol tôi
làm thế nào?
Ông nói quẹ giải hết thế nào để cho ai
cũng hiểu người ngoài ngành người ta
không biết được thế nào là pion đâu.
Đúng rồi. Lược bài nhiều tốt là gì? Bây
giờ ấy không phải thăng mẫu. Giời ơi
không phải thăng mẫu.
Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ người nào
người ta chỉ có HC hơi một cái thôi các
bạn cho vào viện luôn đúng không? Các
bạn giảm cái tiêu chí đi đúng không? Các
bạn lụm nhiều lên đúng không? Lụm nhiều
lên thì các bạn sẽ tăng được cái recod
đúng không? Bây giờ ông nào ra ngoài
đường ông đấy có y mặt đỏ một cái thôi
các bạn cho vào viện luôn không cần khám
gì cả. Tăng recol. Thế muốn tăng prion
ra tăng prion có nghĩa là ông nào mới
phải nằm liệt giường rồi không thở oxy
rồi các bạn mới cho vào viện đ không
đúng rồi khắt khe hơn chính xác
rồi
được chưa đấy là hai ví dụ đây là hai ví
dụ hai ví dụ được chưa
rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không chúng
ta vẫn còn hai ví dụ nữa cơ chúng ta còn
hai ví dụ nữa cơ bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
nữa Không
có nào có hỏi gì nữa không?
Thế bây giờ tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Ví dụ
thứ ba đi. Cái ví dụ này nó sẽ khó hơn
một tí thì mình sẽ không nói về Covid
nữa. Mình lại quay về cái ví dụ về bệnh
ung thư. Được chưa? Nào. Bây gi chúng ta
có hai class. Class ung thư là class
positive. Class khỏe mạnh không hẳn khỏe
mạnh mà class không bị ung thư thì là
negative đúng không? Tất nhiên là class
ung thư sẽ class thiểu số. Class phải
mạnh à class còn lại là class đa số rồi
đúng không? Thì bây giờ thì các bạn bây
giờ mình muốn xây dựng ví dụ Vinmx họ
muốn mình sử dụng cái mô hình để dự án
xem người bị ung thư hay không thì theo
các bạn bây giờ nếu coi class ung thư là
class positive thì tôi sẽ phải tập trung
vào tối ưu precision tôi tập trung tôi t
bây giờ
tập trung vào cái gì bây giờ
nào bây giờ chúng bị ung thư đúng không
bây giờ với ung thư tôi sẽ tập trung vào
pion rec bây giờ
Tập trung vào prion hay recol bây giờ?
Prision thì là chất lượng, recol thì là
số lượng.
F1 thì chả có gì để hỏi nữa rồi. F1 thì
chả có gì để hỏi nữa.
F1 thì mình không có gì mình hỏi nữa
rồi.
Và các bạn hiểu nhá. Như này nhá. Trong
tất cả những cái bài toán khi mà tôi bảo
là tôi tối ưu cái ông này thì có nghĩa
là tôi vẫn phải đảm bảo cái ông kia nó ở
cái mức tương đối đúng không? Ví dụ như
này vệ người bị Covid đi tức là tôi tối
ưu recol tức là tôi bắt nh càng nhiều
người càng tốt đúng không? Thì tôi phải
đảm phải là prion nó phải tối thiểu ví
dụ nó là 10% chẳng hạn chứ đúng không?
Chứ tôi cũng không thể nào mà tôi tối ưu
ôm này tôi cho ông kia về không được
đúng không? Không thể nào ví dụ tại vì
là bắt Covid mà bây giờ muốn recolka cao
tôi cho cả nước đúng không? Cả nước Việt
Nam này trăm triệu người tôi cho là
người ta bị Covid hết thì có mà loạn
đúng không? Tức là khi mà mình nói tối
ưu này các bạn hiểu là gì? Tôi phải làm
sao tôi tối đa hóa một ông trong khi tôi
vẫn đảm bảo ông kia nó phải trên một cái
ngưỡng tối thiểu nào đấy. Được chưa? Thế
nào không mình nói ví dụ về bệnh ung thư
nói do bệnh ung thư luôn được chưa nào
với cái ví dụ này theo các bạn tôi phải
tập trung vào tôi tập trung vào rec và
lý do là vì sao lý do là vì sao
cái mô hình dự đ bị ung thư phải tập
trung vào cái gì
tập trung vào cái
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Bạn thì vào prion, bạn vào recon
Nào bạn nào có thể giải thích mình xem
là theo các bạn vì sao các bạn chọn
vision hay theo các bạn vì sao các bạn
chọn rec nào
các bạn hãy cố gắng các bạn tìm cách nào
giải thích cho dễ hiểu tí đâu. Coi như
lớp này toàn người ngu đi. Coi như lớp
này toàn người ngu. Có cái nào giải
thích dễ hiểu một tí không?
Có cái nào dễ hiểu mà người nào ta chả
hiểu gì về ai người ta cũng có thể hiểu
được không?
Mình gợi ý nhá. Các bạn biết là các bạn
muốn biết là cần cái gì hơn các bạn đặt
trong bài toán thực tế đi. Đem nó vào
bài toán thử tế coi như mình đang xây
dựng thực đi. Không phải mình đang demo,
không phải mình đang mô phỏng. coi nó là
một bài toán trong thực tế đi.
Hãy đặt nó vào bài toán trong thực tế
đi.
Tất nhiên cả hai loại lỗi đều tồi rồi
đúng không? Nhưng các bạn thử nghĩ xem
lỗi lại một, lối lại hai cái nào tồi hơn
đúng không? Muốn biết là cần pi/c các
bạn phải xem lỗi lại một lỗ lại hai cái
nào tồi hơn đúng không?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Nào nhá. Bây giờ cả cho mình hỏi nhá.
Thế bây giờ dễ lắm. Bây giờ đặt vào đ
thực tế là viết ngay nhá. Thế bây giờ
nhá giả sử đi à ngày mai là chủ nhật
đúng không? Mai chủ nhật thì không về
rồi. Ngày kia đi. Ngày kia thứ hai sáng
ngày kia bây giờ các bạn không đi học
không đi làm nữa. Sáng ngày kia bây giờ
cả lớp đi khám tầm soát ung thư. Được
chưa? Sáng thứ hai cả lớp đi vào VinMX
khám tô sát ung thư. Thì bây giờ các bạn
cho mình hỏi nhá. Các bạn cho mình hỏi
này, trong trường hợp mà các bạn khám
ung thư ấy mà ra cái kết quả là các bạn
bị ung thư được chưa? Tức là dương tính
nó đúng không? Các bạn đi khám ung thư
mà ra kết quả là các bạn bị ung thư thì
việc đầu tiên các bạn sẽ làm là các bạn
sẽ làm cái gì? Các bạn
khóc.
Điều gì không? Đánh khám báo gia đình.
Các bạn sẽ làm gì? Các bạn sẽ làm gì?
Đúng rồi. Đi tay khám đúng không các
bạn? Phải đi tay khám. Đi tay khám đúng
không? Làm gì có ông nào bị đi khung thư
mày mẹ mày mẹ mày tin luôn đúng không
các bạn? Mình chưa bị bao giờ nhưng mà
mình khẳng định các bạn luôn là nếu
chẳng may nói dạ nếu nói dại mình bị
những bệnh nghiêm trọng thấy kiểu gì vẫn
phải tái khám đúng không không không nào
đi khám một phát mày đi điều trị luôn cả
đúng không phải đi khám chỗ khác đúng
không thì tức là trong cái trường hợp
này ấy đúng không cái dự đoán của cái dự
đoán của mình nó là sai thì đúng rồi
đúng không nhưng mà cái hậu quả để lại
nó cũng không quá nghiêm trọng nó nó
cũng chả nó nó cũng chả gây ra chết
người đúng không cùng lắm là các bạn ăn
chửi thôi đúng không cùng lắm là các bạn
ăn chửi thôi chứ còn nó cũng không cũng
không ảnh hưởng đến tính mạng con người
cũng không ảnh hưởng gì đến hoàn hình
thế giới cả đúng Không đúng không? Đây
kiểu gì người ta chả đi khám chỗ khác
đúng không? Đời nào người ta bị ung thư
người ta bị kết quả ung thư người ta đi
đi hóa trị luôn. Không làm gì có chuyện
đấy đúng không? Thế bây giờ đổi lại nào.
Đổi lại nào. Thế bây giờ bây giờ nếu thứ
hai các bạn đi khám mà bây giờ kết quả
là các bạn âm tính là các bạn chả bị làm
sao cả thì các bạn sẽ làm việc gì đầu
tiên các bạn.
Nếu mà kết quả là âm tính các bạn không
bị làm sao cả các bạn sẽ làm gì?
Ừ thì về nằm ngủ đúng không? Thế các bạn
thấy không? Tức là gì? đều là kết quả
sai nhưng mà rõ ràng phản ứng của con
người nó sẽ khác nhau. Tại vì sao? Nó
dựa trên một cái tâm lý của con người.
Đó là gì? Chúng ta sẽ không tin những
cái gì bất thường đúng không? Chúng ta
sẽ ít những cái gì nó bất thường hơn
đúng không? Khi chúng ta đi khám ai mà
chẳng có tâm lý là gì? Tôi đi khám cho
cho có thôi đúng không? Tôi đi khám cho
có cho nó yên tâm thôi chứ còn tôi có bị
bệnh gì đâu. Tôi vẫn ăn chơi mà. Đúng
không? Đúng không? Đúng không? Thế nên
là khi chúng ta đã suy nghĩ như vậy rồi,
nếu kết quả nó vẫn như vậy ấ chúng ta sẽ
về nhà ăn chơi nhảy múa thôi đúng không?
Chứ làm gì có ông nào ra kết quả âm tính
mà lại còn đi khám chỗ khác nữa đúng
không? Nhưng mà kết quả khi mà kết quả
nó không như chúng ta mong muốn nó lại
là chuyện khác đúng không? Thế các bạn
cứ tưởng tượng xem tất nhiên là lỗi loại
một lỗ loại hai nó đều tồi rồi đúng
không? Nó sẽ tồi nó ảnh hưởng đến sức
khỏe nó ảnh hưởng đến danh tiếng của
bệnh viện của các bạn. Tức là rất nhiều
thứ. Thế nhưng tóm lại là gì? Nếu các
bạn có bảo là một ông ông đấy khỏe mạnh
ấy, các bạn bảo ông đấy là ông đấy bị
ung thư thì kiểu gì ông đấy cũng sẽ đi
khám ở chỗ khác thôi và sẽ phát hiện ra
là không bị làm sao cả. Thì nó cũng chả
để ảnh hưởng gì, nó quá nặng nề cả đúng
không? Người ta biết cái bài report là
hết thôi đúng không? Thế nhưng trường
hợp ngược lại một người mà người ta bị
ung thư thật mà các bạn lại không tìm
ra, các bạn bảo người ta khỏe mạnh,
người ta về người ta vẫn uống bia, người
ta vẫn thịt thà, người ta vẫn ăn chơi
nhảy muối bình thường đúng người ta
không hóa trị, không điều trị kịp thời
thì người ta sẽ chết nhanh hơn đúng
không? Thì rõ ràng cái việc là các bạn
bảo mọi người ung thư là người ta khỏe
mạnh ấy là nó sẽ nghiêm trọng hơn rất
nhiều với cái lỗi còn lại đúng không?
Thì có nghĩa là gì? Trong trường hợp này
chúng ta phải cố gắng làm sao chúng ta
tối ưu là gì? Tìm ra được càng nhiều
người bị ung thư thì càng tốt. Tức là
gì? Tức là tôi phải tối ưu cái recol.
Tối ưu recol thì tôi phải chấp nhận là
gì? Là pion nó sẽ thấp. Tức là gì? sẽ có
nhiều ông mà tôi sẽ báo nhầm là ông ấy
bị thư đúng không? Tất nhiên trong thực
tế cái cỗ máy người ta sẽ có những cái
thứ trong thực tế những cái cỗ máy vậy
người ta sẽ không bao giờ nó sẽ ra cái
dự đoán tuyệt đối là 0 đến với 1 đâu. Nó
sẽ không kiểu là một là ung thư không là
không ung thư đâu. Nó lại ra một cái kết
quả là một cái số phần một cái số phăm
tức là ông này 80% là ung thư. Kiểu kiểu
như vậy giống kiểu đi xét nghiệm ADN ấy
đúng không? Làm gì có ai xét nghiệm là
chỉ ra kết quả là bố con hay không nó sẽ
là ông này với ông kia là 99% là bố con
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy thì đây nó cũng
y như vậy nhưng mà đây mình đang đơn gi
đơn giản hóa là gì? Là tôi chỉ có hai
cái class thôi đúng không? Thì rõ ràng
với này tôi sẽ cần tập trung vào recol
hơn đúng không? Tìm được càng nhiều
người bị ung thư thì càng tốt. Chấp nhận
là gì? Là sẽ có nhiều ông đấy khỏe mạnh
mà tôi lại bảo nhập ông đấy bị ung thư
đúng không? Đấy. Thế đấy là bài toán về
bệnh thông thường nhá. Thông thường
những cái bài toán liên quan đến y tế,
liên quan đến bệnh người ta thường hay
có cái xu hướng người ta tập trung vào
recol nhiều hơn nhá. Thông thường với
những bài toán có liên quan đến bệnh,
liên quan đến ung thư các thứ ý người ta
sẽ không ung thư mà tất cả các nh bệnh
nói chung chung ấy người ta thường hay
có xu hướng ta tập trung vào cái recn
mình phải đý khám này sang tuần đi khám
này lần trước khám lần nhất 1 năm rồi s
tuần mới đi khám này
ừ tức là thường liên quan đến y tế liên
quan đến bệnh viện người ta hay có cái
xu hướng mình không nói tất cả nhưng mà
hay có cái xu hướng là tập trung vào
recol nhiều hơn đấy kiểu
tìm hi bỏ sót đấy đúng không?
Nó các bạn nó nó giống như kiểu này các
bạn ạ. Ngày xưa bạn học đại học ấy, các
bạn biết học đại học các bạn có cái món
là là là là đi xin phúc khảo ấy. Xin
phúc khảo là sao các bạn nhỉ? Thế nào
gọi là đi xin phúc khảo các bạn?
Cái nào gọi là đi xin phúc khảo các bạn?
Đi học đại học hay món đi xin phúc khảo
là như nào? À xin chấm lại đúng không?
Các bạn thấy không? Các bạn cứ tưởng
tượng mà xem mấy cái ông đi xin phúc
khảo ấy toàn nhữ ông hai ba điểm xin
phúc khảo. Tại vì lúc đầu mình nghĩ là
điểm đấy cao hơn mà c điểm đấy thấp hơn.
Tức là nó không giống như mình mong đợi
đúng không? Chứ còn ông nào mà nhận điểm
9 đến 10 mình chả thấy ông nào được 10
điểm đi xin phúc khảo bao giờ cả đúng
không? Chả ông nào 10 điểm đi xin phúc
khảo bao giờ đúng không?
Đấy nó thì bệnh nó chúng ta bao giờ cũng
có tâm lý thôi. Cái gì mà tồi hơn cái
tồi hơn thứ mà mà chúng ta nghĩ chúng ta
mới đi mới đi kiểm tra lại. Còn tốt hơn
tốt bằng hoặc tốt hơn chả ai đi kiểm tra
lại bao giờ cả.
Mình còn nhớ ngày xưa học Bách Khoa có
cái môn cái môn xử lý cái gì chả biết
nữa. Mình làm bài xong mình nghĩ là về
tám điểm hộ cung thì thầy cho 10 điểm.
Mình cũng chả đi xin phúc khảo mà biết.
Mình nghĩ chắc là chấm xài đâu đấy là
vào điểm sai nhưng mà mình cũng chả xin
phúc khảo bao giờ cả đúng không? Tốt tội
gì phúc khảo đúng không?
Rồi thế thôi đúng không? Thế trường này
chúng ta lại cần vào rec
theo các bạn nhá. Theo các bạn nhá theo
các bạn nhá. Mấy bạn mà làm về bên H ấy,
làm về bên tuyển dụng ấy, theo các bạn
nhá. Khi mà người ta gửi email thông ờ
đến các cái ứng cử viên là anh chị có
quan tâm đến cái job này hay không? Theo
các bạn là các cái bạn HI này các bạn
tập trung vào cái gì? Tập trung vào pion
hay tập trung vào rec?
Recall đúng không? Mình cũng nghĩ thế
đúng không? Thông thường là recall đúng
không? Pression tức là gì? Ta cái job mà
về web developer là tôi chỉ gửi ông nào
kỹ năng về web thôi. Còn recall là gì?
Cũng cứ hôm nào IT tôi cứ gửi cứ gửi bừa
đi đã đúng không? Gửi nhầm của nó bỏ sót
đúng không? Đấy đúng không? Có trường
hợp tôi cần về pion, có thể trường dục
tôi cần về rec đúng không?
Thông thường chúng ta cứ hay quan niệm
là chất lượng thì cần hơn là số lượng
nhưng mà không phải như vậy. Có rất
nhiều bài toán lại cần số lượng. Có rất
nhiều bài toán tôi cần cái độ bao phủ.
Đấy, prion nó ưu tiên vào độ chính xác
còn rec nó ưu tiên vào độ bao phủ.
Pression tập trung vào chất lượng, rec
tập trung vào số lượng.
Rồi còn một câu nữa khó hơn chúng ta
nghỉ giá xong chúng ta xử lý nhá. Còn
một câu nữa nhá.
Nghỉ dút nhá. Giờ 5 phút nhá.
Mới mới được lên báo này các bạn này.
Vừa đấy bạn mình gửi cho mới được lên
báo này.
Chắc đây là lần đầu là lần cuối được lên
mắ.
Mình vừa mình vừa được gửi năng dọc đâên
được gửi
cái chỗ này mình nhớ là các em khoảng 1
năm mình đi một cái một cái studio.
Studio này nó chuyên chụp ảnh cho các
bạn nữ mỗi mình là nam vào đâ nhờ phải
đánh phấn mà đánh phấn hơi quá tay nó
như này. Sau đó phải nhờ các bạn ấy chèn
thêm tóc vào đây. Chỗ này lúc đầu là
không có tóc đâu. Người ta chèn chèn
thêm vào đấy. Đành cái ảnh này
thô cái này chắc là in ra đóng khung
treo tường chắc là không bao giờ có cơ
hội lên đây lần hai nữa.
Ừ.
được
Không biết bao giờ về đến ngày đấy.
Cái gì đấy nhỉ?
No nhỉ?
Cho mình xin phép 1 phút nhé.
Mình
một tí nhá.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
1 2 Đâu s?
[tiếng cười]
Ừ.
Bây giờ hàng ngày mình cứ toàn lên
Linkin mình check xem có cái gì mới về
ai không ch người ta lọc sẵn cho bài
luôn.
nhiều
là của khóa sau rồi. Open claw thì mình
cũng thấy nhiều người nói về lắm nhưng
mà công việc của mình mình cũng không
cần dùng nhiều đến nó. Mình cũng là mình
mình mình có dùng thử nhưng mà công việc
của mình nó không nó không dùng nhiều
đến cái đấy. Nó không dùng nhiều đến
đấy. Bây giờ mình thấy cái cây công cụ
khác nó cũng khá là ok rồi.
Mình thì không phải dùng nhiều nhưng mà
mình thấy nó khá là nhìn qua các cái
cho, các cái view giới thiệu của các cái
YouTuber nước ngoài mình thấy khá là ok.
Mình thấy khá là ok. Dùng có vẻ là cũng
ok.
Đ là của của khóa sau nhá.
Ôi giời ừ ừ em nói đi.
>> Trước em có đọc được một cái bài báo nó
nói về việc
xử lý tập dữ liệu liên quan đến ảnh chụp
city não anh
>> anh. Ừ MRI
MRI nhở cái ảnh chụp cắt lớp đúng không?
Ừ ok
>> đúng rồi anh chụp cắt lớp xong nó có kết
hợp giữa nó có kết hợp giữa bộ encoder
của thằng Transformer
>> rồi
>> và bộ decoder của thằng Unit. Rồi
>> xong nó nói là thằng Transformer thì nó
mạnh về hiểu hiểu được toàn cục nhưng mà
nó yếu bị cục bộ. Còn thằng Unit thì
ngược lại nó hiểu toàn cục nó hiểu toàn
cục kém nhưng mà nó hiểu cục bộ tốt.
>> Thì em không có rõ là nó thằng
Transformer này toàn cục là như thế nào.
Còn thằng kia nó hiểu cục bộ là như thế
nào.
>> Đây này. Toàn cục như này. Toàn cục ý
tức là cả cái ảnh ấy nó nhìn được cả cái
ảnh đấy luôn. Thì đấy là toàn cục. Còn
cục bộ là hiểu những cái chi tiết nhỏ
trên cái ảnh ấy. Đấy là cục bộ. Đấy đấy
là ý nghĩa của t cục bộ. Nó ghép hai cái
thằng lại với nhau thành một cái model
tên là trans unit. Trans unit à nghe hay
nhở. Xem nào.
Trans
unet
đây.
Ui từ 2023 thì cũng cũng thì cũng cũ
rồi. Đấy đây cho Americ
thân Unet thì cũng đã đ là là cũng là là
cái mô hình dành cho dành cho nước việ y
tế rồi. Bản thân UNET cũng là y tế rồi.
X xem nó ghi cái gì không? Nhưng mà để
các phải để sau giờ này nhá chứ không
bắt các bạn khác ngồi nhìn thì ấy quá
nhá. Được không? Ok. Xem. Ờ đúng rồi. Nó
lấy nửa của unet này. Nửa trước là nửa
trước này thì là phần là phần là phần
bớt rồi. Lấy nửa đầu của Transformer thì
là bớt rồi.
Rồi ok.
Ờ không khóa LM vậy ạ. Asient là mình
dạy về cái những cái kiến thức kia bản
từ từ đầu các bạn không cần phải có có
nền tảng thì tốt không có cũng chả làm
sao cả. Nào các bạn tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá
tiếp nhá. Thế bây giờ vừa rồi là ba ví
dụ rồi đúng không? Ba ví dụ rồi đúng
không? Ví dụ cuối sẽ khó hơn nhá. Các
bạn nghe thật kỹ nhá. Ví dụ cuối này nó
sẽ khó hơn ba ví dụ vừa rồi nhá.
Bây giờ mình muốn đem cái
đem cái bài toán phân loại này vào trong
lĩnh vực luật pháp, lĩnh vực tư pháp
luật pháp. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ giả sử
mình muốn mình muốn xây dựng một cái con
quan tòa AI. Được chưa? Quan tòa AI.
Quan tòa AI có nghĩa gì? Tức là bây giờ
đứng trước vành móng ngựa sẽ là một gọi
là gì? Gọi là bị cáo à bị cáo à đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ phải
phán được con cái cái con này nó sẽ phải
phán xem là ví dụ bị cá này là những cái
bệnh à xư bạn những những cái tội ví dụ
như là giết người cấp của hiếp dâm biển
thủ đi mấy cái tội có phải tương đối
nặng đi chứ mấy cái tội nhẹ quá thì cũng
chả đáng để đưa ra con tòa đúng không?
Đấy những cái tội như vậy thì bây giờ
các bạn cho mình hỏi này theo các bạn
này bây giờ với những cái tội như thế
đúng không? Thế bây giờ cái con con này
nó chỉ ra có thể một trong hai cái phán
quyết thôi. Một là người này có tội và
hai là người này vô tội. Tất nhiên class
có tội là class positive rồi. Để nó là
các nó là các thiểu số mà đúng không?
Class có tội thì là positive, class vô
tội thì là class negative đúng không? Có
tội là positive, vô tội là negative. Thì
các bạn cho mình hỏi này, theo các bạn
bây giờ ấy cái con cái con quan tòa AI
này của mình ấy đúng không? Theo các bạn
là bây giờ khi nó đưa ra phán quyết như
vậy, theo các bạn nó phải tập trung vào
prision hay nó tập trung vào recall. Và
lý do là vì sao?
Nào
ờ class positive là class có tội, class
negative là class vô tội đúng không? Thì
con chạ con cái con cái con quan tòa EI
này bây giờ nó phải phán cứ xem là cái
người đứng trước vành bóng ngựa người ta
có tội hay không tội đúng không? Thì bây
giờ theo các bạn là bây giờ nó phải tập
trung vào prion hay tập trung vào rec
bây giờ. Câu này khó bạn nhá. Cứ người
nói kỹ đi. Câu này khó. Câu này khó nhá.
Câu này khó.
Ừ, rất nhiều quan điểm này.
Cần phun hay cần vic này?
Ừ.
Nào, thử thêm một hai phút nữa đi.
Nào, tôi cần prion. Theo các bạn là mình
tập trung vào prion hay là tập trung vào
rec bây giờ
hầu hết các bạn xem nào. Có bạn bảo
prion, các bạn bảo recall.
Nào các bạn khác nữa thì sao?
Ừ thì coi như là không dùng AI nhưng mà
coi như là mình sẽ bây giờ mình là một
mình là một người bình thường đi. Cái
này không hẳn là AI. Tức là bây giờ mình
là một quan tòa là bằng xương bằng thịt
đi. Thì theo các bạn bây giờ khi mình ra
phán quyết mình phải tập trung vào hay
là rec đúng không?
Cái magic này là dùng để đánh giá chung
chung cho bài toán phân loại chứ không
phải là chỉ cho là AI không. Con người
cũng thế mà. Đ
thì thế này nhá các bạn này. Thật ra ấy
với những câu hỏi như này ấ nó cũng chả
có kết quả đúng hay sai đâu. Nó chỉ là
lộng luận thôi. Ví dụ với những cái khóa
trước của mình thì có những bạn có lậm
luận là gì? À ừ tức là bây giờ các bạn
thấy là tóm lại là bây giờ chúng ta phải
đánh phải đánh giá xem là bây giờ các
bạn phán nhầm một người vô tội là có tội
với cả thả nhầm một thằng có tội là vô
tội thì cái nào nó tồi hơn đúng không?
Tất nhiên là hai cái nó hai cái nó cùng
tồi đúng không? Hai cái nó cùng tồi đúng
không? Bắt nhầm cái ông vô tội thì cũng
tồi mà thả nhầm cái thằng có tội thì nó
cũng tồi đúng không? Nhưng mà rõ ràng
phải có một cái trường hợp này nó phải
tồi hơn đúng không? Theo các bạn giữa
hai trường hợp đấy trường hợp nào tồi
hơn?
Bắt nhầm người vô tội và thả nhầm thằng
có tội. Thế nào tồi hơn?
Hai cái thì đều tồi rồi nhưng phải có
một cái nó tồi hơn.
Bắt nhầm tồi hơn hay thả nhầm tồi hơn?
Nếu là mình nhá. Nếu là mình ở đây như
mình nói là cái này nó không có theo
mình nó không có đúng hay sai nhưng mà
ví dụ với quan điểm cá nhân của mình
theo mình thì mình sẽ mình sẽ tập trung
vào precision hơn. Tức là gì? Tức là
theo mình cái việc là bắt nhầm một người
vô tội nó sẽ tồi hơn thả nhầm một kẻ có
tội. Tất nhiên những cái khóa trước của
mình có bạn mới bảo ngay là thầy ơi bây
giờ thả một thằng có tội, thảo một thằng
giết người hiếp dâm chẳng hạn b thả nó
ra bì nó lại đi ra ngoài nó lại giết
người nó lại hiếp dâm tiếp đúng không?
thì đúng đúng là thả ra có cơ hội có khả
năng là nó sẽ tái phạm thật. Thế nhưng
mà theo mình là so với cái việc mà
theo mình là cái việc mà để một người
người ta người người người à
người ta vô tội mà bắt người ta vào ngồi
tù thì nó sẽ
có vẻ nó là cái không chấp nhận được. Ví
dụ như mình thì ngày xưa mình thấy là
những cái báo kiểu báo an ninh, báo pháp
luật ấy người ta hay có một cái góc
người ta nói về những cái vụ án oan chục
năm hai chục năm ấy đúng không? Các bạn
thấy không? những cái những cái vụ này
những cái vụ mà rất là hay được nhận
được sự chú ý của của của dữ luận đúng
không? Tất nhiên chúng ta sẽ có những
cái thứ là chúng ta sẽ có phiên sơ thẩm
phúc thẩm nhưng mà ở đây hãy coi như
đúng không? Hãy coi như là đơn giản hóa
bài toán đi là bây giờ tôi chỉ kết tội
là có hay không thế thôi đúng không? Chứ
còn những cái thứ mà sơ thẩm phúc thẩm
các thứ thì chúng ta sẽ để hạo hồi sau
đúng không? Thế bạn nào mà các bạn có
bạn bè người quen làm trong lĩnh vực
luật pháp ấy đúng không các bạn thấy là
ví dụ công an chẳng hạn đúng không? Họ
chỉ họ chỉ có họ chỉ có tức là cái câu
khẩu hiệu họ tức là gì? là tức là không
không bắt nhầm người vô tội đúng không?
Chứ làm gì có ông nào hô hà là tôi sẽ cố
gắng bắt được nh càng nhiều kẻ trộm là
càng nhiều người có tội càng tốt đâu
đúng không? Bao giờ người ta cái tiêu
chí của người ta cũng là gì? Các bạn có
bạn bè nào mà làm về công an bây giờ ờ
làm làm ở bên công an ấy đúng không? Thì
các bạn hoặc làm ở bên luật ấy bao giờ
bạn thấy người ta sẽ tập trung vào việc
là gì? Là tránh bắt nhầm người người ta
người ta vô tội đúng không? Chứ làm gì
có ông nào đi đi khoe tự hào là tôi bắt
được nhiều kẻ có tội lắm đúng không? Chỉ
có là tôi không tôi không bắt nhầm người
thôi đúng không? Ngày xưa mình nhớ cái
rất là lâu rồi, chắc phải hơn chục năm
rồi mình đọc một cái bài báo ở một cái
nước ở Nam Mỹ, không biết là Argentina
hay là Uruguay gì đấy. Có một vụ như này
tức là có một vụ cái vụ đấy nó phải đâ
khoảng 20 30 năm rồi. Tức cái thời mà
ADN nó còn chưa phát triển á tức là có
một có một thảng nó phạm cái tội gì đấy
cũng khá là nghiêm trọng. Nó nó nó khá
là nghiêm trọng. Thế thì người ta biết
là nó là người có tội rồi nhưng mà khốn
lỗi là khốn lỗi là nó có một ông anh em
sinh đôi. Người ta chỉ biết là cái thằng
có tội là một trong hai thằng đấy nhưng
mà cụ thể là thằng nào người ta không
biết. Tại vì là camera thì cái độ phân
giải của camera ngoài đường các bạn cũng
cũng biết rồi đúng không? Mà thời đấy
chưa có ADN. Người ta chỉ biết là chắc
chắn là một trong hai thằng có tội nhưng
mà mỗ tội là hai thằng này nó lại nó lại
không khai ra thằng kia. Thế và cuối
cùng thì người ta phải xử là gì? Người
ta cung người ta phải thả cả hai thằng.
Thả cả hai thằng tại vì bây giờ mà cho
bây giờ mà go vào tù có nghĩa là bắt
người bắt người lương thiện người ta vào
tù rồi đúng không? Còn bây giờ thả ra
thì đấy vậy đâ t gì t người ta ưu tiên
hơn cái việc gì là thả à thả nhầm cái
thằng có tội ấy còn hơn là bắt một người
vô tội người ta vào người ta ngồi đúng
không? Tất nhiên ở đây như mình nói là
theo mình nó cũng chả có cái phương án
nó là đúng hoàn toàn đâu mà nó chỉ là
cái việc gọi là lập luận chúng ta xem là
cái nào cũng thấy có vẻ có lý hơn. Có
thể trong cái trường hợp này trong cái
loại tội này thì cái phương án này nó có
lý hơn. Trong cái trường hợp kia thì có
phương án kia nó có lý hơn.
Thì quay cái víu này mình muốn nói với
các bạn một cái điều là sau này ấ khi mà
các bạn đi làm ấy các bạn sẽ thường các
bạn sẽ ví dụ các bạn làm data scientist
các bạn sẽ không làm kiểu một mình đâu
mà các bạn sẽ có một cái chim toàn data
scientist với nhau
thì trong quá trình các bạn làm về cùng
ấy sẽ có rất nhiều những cái tình huống
mà các bạn sẽ cần phải tranh luận xem là
theo các bạn là tụ theo theo bạn cái
trường hợp này tôi sẽ đi theo cái hướng
nào tôi hướng đi hướng chất lượng hay là
số lượng thế thì cái việc mà nãy giờ
mình hỏi các bạn là confusion recon ấy
là để làm gì là để sau này ấy khi mà các
bạn đi làm khi mà trong cái một Cái chim
ấy nó có cái sự bất đồng về mặt quan
điểm đúng không? Bất đồng về mặt quan
điểm. Tức là ông này nghĩ theo hướng
này, ông kia theo hướng kia. Thì các bạn
biết là các bạn sẽ cần phải có những cái
tranh luận. Tranh luận đây không phải là
tôi sẽ phải bảo vệ ý tôi bằng mọi giá
đúng không? Tức là nếu mà tôi thấy là
cái ý kiến của đối phương nó hợp lý thì
tôi cũng sẽ ok thôi. Thế nhưng mà ít
nhất là mình phải có cái khả năng mình
bảo vệ cái quan điểm của mình. Thì có
trong quá trình làm như thế thì theo
mình đây là cái điều rất là quan trọng.
Tại vì khi mà mình thấy là thứ nhất là
hoặc là mình thấy là quan điểm mình đúng
mình đi theo cái quan điểm đấy. Hai là
mình nếu mình theo quan điểm khác mình
phải mình phải thực sự mình công nhận là
là là cái hướng người ta là là đúng thì
lúc mình làm nó mới thoải mái được. Chứ
còn làm theo kiểu là tôi biết cái hướng
này không đúng nhưng mà tôi cứ bị é tôi
phải làm thì nó sẽ rất là khó chịu đúng
không? Trong quá trình mình làm rất
nhiều nhiều thì không hẳn nhưng mà tức
là thi thoảng sẽ có những lúc mà hai bên
sẽ phải tranh luận xem là là là cái
phương án nào nó phù hợp. Thì đây cũng
như vậy. Tức là gì? Chúng ta đưa ra cái
quan điểm, chúng ta phải có khả năng
chúng ta bảo vệ quan điểm đấy. Bảo vệ
không phải là nhắm mơ món lợi kiểu gì
tôi cũng phải tôi là đúng, tôi là số
một. Thế nhưng mà tôi cũng phải có những
cái cách tôi đưa ra cái lâu luận của
mình đúng không? Và đưa lâu luận làm sao
để có thể mà ai cũng có thể hiểu được
đúng không? Để có thể dễ dàng trao đổi
với nhau đúng không? Đấy thì đấy là cái
ví dụ cuối cùng được chưa? V cái víụ
>> thầy thầy cái này mình có thể dùng hai
model hai model khác nhau trên cùng một
cái population đúng không? Ví dụ như là
cái modồn một cái là nói về recall thì
mình catch được mình lấy được khoảng
bắt được nhiều người còn hơn là bỏ sót
phải không? Thế xong mình lại lm một cái
modồn thứ hai
>> cũng trên cùng một cái số lượng người
population như vậy thì nó sẽ nói là ô
trong số những cái thằng mà mình catch
được cái mô đồn đầu á mình lấy được cái
mô đầu có cái thằng này nó sẽ có thể là
nhiều khả năng sẽ bị phạm tội hơn thì
mình kiểu mình join hai cái đó lại với
nhau xong mìnhừ
>> ờ
>> bắt cái thằng mình nghĩ lại.
>> Vâng [tiếng cười] cái cách đấy thì cũng
được. Thế nhưng cái đấy nó sẽ có một cái
vấn đề như thế này. Tức là nếu hai cái
mô hình này ấy mình mà cùng huấn luyện
trên cùng một cái tập dữ liệu thì nó sẽ
dẫn đến cái việc là hai mô hình nó sẽ
cái nó conflict với nhau. Conflict là
ông này thì đỉa kết quả của ông kia. Tức
là cái cách đấy nếu mình làm theo kiểu
là hai m hai cái mùi hình này nó huấn
luyện trên cái bộ rượu nó khác nhau ấy
thì ok nó sẽ có cái sự đa dạng. Thế còn
nếu mà nó huấn luyện trên cùng một cái
bộ dữ liệu, một là chúng nó sẽ ra những
cái cái dự án nó năn ná nhau đông giống
nhau th ông này thế nào ông kia cũng như
thế. Và hai là gì? Hai là cái hai nó sẽ
conflict hẳn với nhau. Thì trong hai
trường hợp thì ờ nhìn chung là sẽ có
những cái thứ mình sẽ phải giải quyết
thêm. Thấy ra mình là như thế. Tất nhiên
là cái việc mà sử dụng nhiều mô hình nó
sẽ nó sẽ có cái ưu điểm của nó. Nhưng mà
ví dụ này thường ấy khi người ta hay sử
dụng nhiều mô hình người ta hay làm kiểu
như này. Ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ mình muốn sử
dụng một cái mô hình để có thể phân loại
à để có thể dự đoán cái quốc tịch của
mọi người đúng không? Thì bây giờ thay
vì tôi dùng một cái mô hình phân loại nó
phải dự đoán ra 100 à 200 class khác
nhau. Có 200 nước mà đúng không? Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ có một cái mô hình đầu tiên
tôi phân loại châu lục. Châu Á, Châu Âu,
Châu Phi, Châu Mỹ, Châu Đại Dương. Sau
tôi sẽ có năm cái mô hình ở dưới để mỗi
một cái châu lực tôi lại phân lại ra cụ
thể. Tức là nó theo kiểu là nó theo kiểu
chạy kiểu phân phân tầng ấy. Đấy thì nó
chúng ta sẽ hay làm kiểu như thế. Thế
còn kiểu là cái mô hình sau nó lọc nó
file tool cái quả mô hình trước thì cũng
ok. Đấy nhưng mà cái đấy nó sẽ cần liên
quan đến mình phải đảm bảo là cái dữ
liệu nó phải như thế nào đấy. Thế chứ
còn hai ông mà cùng dữ liệu nhau thì khả
năng cao là hai ông lại ra cái khoản nó
giống nhau thì cao lắm.
Thì nhưng mà như cái một cái cái cái ví
dụ về la tòa như thế này nó cũng rất
giống kiểu như là cũng có được tức là sẽ
sơ thẩm và phúc thẩm đúng không? Có
những người họ họ nghĩ họ không có tội
họ họ họ để đơn họ xin khám lại
>> thì kiểu nó cũng là như kiểu hai cái hai
cái khác nhau. Ừ ừ được
rồi.
Có nào câu hỏi tình lượng không?
Đấy nhá các bạn thấy nhá đúng không? Sau
các bạn đi làm nhá. Nhớ là gì? Với mỗi
mỗi cái bài toán phân loại này ấy sẽ
phải xác định xem là các bạn cần cái gì.
Cion về rec
bất đắc dị lắm mới chọn F1. Nhưng mà một
khi các bạn chọn F1 rồi các bạn sẽ không
không có biết là các bạn phải tối ưu cái
gì đâu. Tại vì là F1 hai ông này nó bình
đẳng với nhau mà đúng không? Chọn F1 rồi
có nghĩa là các bạn sẽ không biết là các
bạn muốn tối ưu các bạn tối ưu cái gì
đúng không? Đấy
thì nãy giờ là những cái matric này đúng
không? Aquacion rec F1 à không xin lỗi
bạn bỏ qua Aquac Prin Record F1 đúng
không? đấy là khi mà các bạn chọn một
class là class positive sau các bạn có
thể phản thắng các bạn đổi vai trò của
hai ông đi và các bạn lại ngồi tính lại
từ đầu đúng không bây giờ cái p1 cho con
chó là positive nó khác cho các lá con
mèo là positive nó khác đúng không thế
còn trong trường hợp các bạn có nhiều
hơn hai class các bạn làm như nào
trong trường hợp có nhiều hơn hai class
làm thế nào bây giờ
trường hợp có nhiều hơn hai class mình
làm thế nào bây giờ tôi có bốn class đi
chó mẹ lợn gà tôi làm thế nào bây giờ
bốn class chó mẹ lợn gà làm thế nào bây
giờ
Bốn class chó m lợn gà th làm thế nào
bây giờ?
Bây giờ tôi muốn tính prion cho con chó
thì tôi làm nào? Bây giờ có bốn con thì
biết bình thường có hai con thì chọn một
positive, một negative bốn con chọn kiểu
gì?
À đúng rồi. Gộp ba con kia lại cho là
negative.
Đúng rồi. Đúng không? Chó và không phải
chó, mèo và không phải mèo, bò và không
phải bò và gà và không phải gà. Đúng
rồi, chính xác đúng không? Khi mà các
bạn có nhiều hơn hai class thì các bạn
chỉ chọn một ông là positive, còn gom
chỗ lại thành một class là negative đúng
không? Đấy.
Thế các bạn nhìn này. Thế tất cả những
cái magic vừa rồi ấ nó đều là những cái
magic nó mang tính chất
đơn lẻ. Đơn lẻ có nghĩa là gì? Các bạn
tưởng tượng này nhá.
Bây giờ ấy tất cả những cái mô hình sau
này các bạn sẽ học là tất cả hầu hết tất
cả các thuật toán trong machining dành
cho bài toán phân loại ấy đúng không? Ví
dụ các bạn chỉ có hai class là class chó
với mèo đi đúng không? Hoặc là người bị
bệnh hay là không ấy thì hầu hết cái mô
hình machining chúng ta ấy nó sẽ không
đưa dự đoán theo kiểu là đây là chó hay
đây là mèo đâu mà nó sẽ làm như nào? Nó
sẽ gán điểm. Nó sẽ gán điểm tức là như
nào? Nó sẽ gán điểm. Ví dụ là cho cái lá
con chó nó gán cho là 70 điểm, con mèo
là 30 điểm hoặc là con chó 40, con mèo
60 đúng không? Thì ông nào là ông lớn
hơn thì cuối cùng cái dự đoán nó sẽ là
về class đấy đúng không? Tức là gì? Tức
là cái dự đoán của mô hình nó sẽ không
phải là chó hay mèo mà nó sẽ đoán là gì?
Là chó là bao nhiêu phần trăm, mèo là
bao nhiêu phần trăm đúng không? Hoặc là
người bị bệnh cũng thế thôi. Cái mô hình
của bạn nó sẽ không nói thẳng là người
này bị bệnh hay không mà ta sẽ nói là
người này có
60% là bị bệnh và 40% là khỏe mạnh đúng
không? Só từ đấy tôi mới lọc ra xem ông
nào là ông đa số ông nào ông quá bán thì
tôi sẽ lấy cái dự án là về ông đấy đúng
không? Hầu v các cái mô hình nó sẽ như
thế đúng không? Thế nhưng mà bây giờ nó
sẽ ra một cái vấn đề như này là nhá. Bây
giờ hãy tưởng tượng đi. Hãy tưởng tượng
là gì? Là bây giờ với bài toán phân loại
nhị phân khi bạn chỉ có hai class thôi
thì bây giờ hãy tưởng tượng là bây giờ
mô hình nó sẽ dự đoán một cái số điểm
cho từng class một và tổng số điểm này
nó sẽ bằng 1. Ví dụ là gì? Cái class con
chó nó cho 0,7 điểm thì con mèo sẽ là
0,3. Con chó là 0,1 con chó con mèo sẽ
là 0,9. Đúng không? Tức là hãy coi như
chúng ta hãy chuẩn hóa cái số điểm đầu
ra này. Đúng không? Là mô hình giống
kiểu bây giờ điểm các bạn đúng không?
Điểm đỗ mà là 60 thì điểm trượt là 40.
Kiểu kiểu như vậy đúng không 60% là đỗ,
40% là trượt. Đúng không? Bệnh cũng như
thế thôi đúng không? 0,7 tức là 70% là
bị bệnh, 30% là không đúng không? Thế
thì thông thường á thông thường ấy chúng
ta sẽ lấy cái giá trị ngưỡng mặc định là
bằng 0,5 là cái giá trị ở giữa. Ngưỡng
có nghĩa là gì? Tức là ví dụ trên cái
ngưỡng đấy thì là class này, dưới ngưỡng
đấy là class kia đúng không? Ví dụ như
bị bị bệnh đi đúng không? ngưỡng là 0,5
thì bây giờ cái số điểm là số điểm bị
bệnh là trên 0,5 thì là bị bệnh còn dưới
0,5 thì là khỏe mạnh đúng không? Đấy tức
là cái giá trị ngưỡng thông thường mặc
định là các ông nằm ở giữa. Điểm mà từ 0
đến 1 thì ngưỡng là 0,5. Điểm từ 0 đến
10 thì ngưỡng là 5. Điểm từ 0 đến 100
thì ngưỡng là 50. Đúng không? Thông
thường cái ngưỡng này sẽ là cái ông chặn
ở giữa. Đấy và hầu hết các cái thuật
toán trong machining nếu các bạn không
thay đổi gì thì cái ngưỡng nó sẽ luôn là
cái ngưỡng ở giữa như vậy. Thế thế nhưng
mà trong quá trình chúng ta sử dụng mô
hình chúng ta sẽ muốn là tập trung vào
prion, tập trung vào recall đúng không?
Thì chúng ta muốn tập trung bằng cái
nào? Chúng ta sẽ phải thay đổi cái
ngưỡng này đi đúng không? Ví dụ nhá. Ví
dụ bây giờ các bạn tưởng tượng đi. Một
cái mô hình nó sẽ dự đoán xem m người có
bị Covid hay không được không? Bây giờ
các bạn giả sử này cái điểm người cái
điểm mô hình nó dự đoán ra cho cho người
bị Covid ấ là một cái con số từ 0 đến 1
đúng không? Ngưỡng là 0,5 tức là gì? Tức
là bây giờ cái số điểm mô hình nó gắn
cho người này trên 0,5 thì là người đấy
bị Covid dưới 0,5 có nghĩa là là người
đấy khỏe đúng không? Thế bây giờ nếu
chúng ta muốn tăng cái vì côn của mô
hình này cho cái bị Covid thì chúng ta
sẽ phải tăng ngưỡng hay là giảm ngưỡng?
Hả các bạn?
Chúng ta sẽ phải tăng ngưỡng hay là giảm
ngưỡng?
Ngưỡng là 0,5 đúng không? Cái mùi sẽ gán
điểm cho một người là một cái con số từ
0 đến 1. Cái điểm này mà trên ngưỡng thì
là chúng ta sẽ bảo là người ta bị bệnh.
Còn dưới ngưỡng là chúng ta bảo người ta
khỏe mạnh. Thế bây giờ chúng ta muốn
tăng cái recol chúng ta muốn tìm ra được
nhiều người bị Covid hơn chúng ta sẽ
phải tăng ngưỡng hay là giảm ngưỡng?
Đúng rồi, giảm ngưỡng đúng không? Mọi
khi là phải cũng bắt đầu xịt sụt xịt rồi
đâ thì mới bảo là bị Covid. Bây giờ chỉ
còn hắt hơi một cái thôi đúng không? Mặt
vẫn trắng thì tôi đã bảo người ta bị
Covid rồi đúng không? Nên các bạn giảm
ngưỡng các bạn sẽ tăng được recolle và
các bạn tăng ngưỡng lên các bạn sẽ tăng
được prion. Tức là gì? Ông nào bây gi
phải nằm liệt giường hôn mê thở oxy rồi
thì tôi mới bảo là bị Covid đúng không?
Đấy tức là gì? Tức là tất cả những cái
giá trị mà tất cả những cái giá trị nhá
bao gồm cả pression reconnect one ấy
chúng nó sẽ phải tính lại nếu các bạn
thay đổi ngưỡng đúng không? mặc định
ngưỡng là 0,5 các bạn sẽ có accuracy thế
này, prion rec như thế này. Nhưng một
khi các bạn xê dịch cái ngưỡng này dù
chỉ một tí thôi là các bạn cũng sẽ phải
ngồi tính lại cả bốn cái matric này đúng
không? Kể cả accuracy đúng không?
Accuracy nó còn không phân biệt là ông
nào nó positive, ông nào negative nhưng
nếu các bạn thay đổi ngưỡng một cái lập
tức các bạn phải ngồi tính lại acion,
recon các bạn cũng sẽ phải ngồi tính lại
hoàn toàn.
Thế thì á những cái magic này ấ nó sẽ
chỉ cho các bạn biết là cái performance
của mô hình tại một ngưỡng cụ thể thôi
mà thông thường cái ngưỡng mặc định là
cái ngưỡng ở giữa đúng không? Mình không
cần biết cái mô hình các bạn điểm cho từ
0 đến 1 thì ngưỡng giữa là 0,5 điểm từ 0
đến 100 ngưỡng giữa là 50 tùy đúng
không? Tóm lại nó là cái ngưỡng ở giữa.
Thế nhưng mà bây giờ tôi sẽ thay đổi cái
ngưỡng này để tôi điều chỉnh để tôi tập
trung vào magic và vision hoặc recall
đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi muốn là tôi
có một cái magic để tôi có thể cho tôi
một cái bức tranh toàn cảnh về
performance của mình ở nhiều ngỡ khác
nhau thì tôi làm thế nào đúng không? Bây
giờ tôi muốn có một cái bức tranh toàn
cảnh để cho tôi biết là cái performance
của cái mô hình này nó thay đổi như thế
nào khi cái ngưỡng của tôi thay đổi từ
bé cho đến lớn thì tôi làm thế nào? Cái
magic này không làm được điều đấy. Đây
đều là những cái magic gọi là những cái
giá trị đơn lẻ đúng không? nó không cho
chúng ta cái góc nhìn toàn cảnh của mô
hình với nhiều cái ngưỡng khác nhau.
Thế bây giờ để chúng ta có được cái góc
nhìn toàn cảnh như vậy, chúng ta sẽ cần
phải có một cái magic mới. Được chưa?
Chúng ta sẽ cần phải có những cái magic
mới. [khịt mũi] Magic mới này là là
những cái magic gì thì các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đầu tiên này, đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ phải
làm quen với hai cái khái niệm mới. Được
chưa? Cái khái niệm đầu tiên người ta
gọi đó là true positive rate true
positive rate nó chính là một cái tên
gọi khác của recol. Được chưa? True
positive rate là một tên gọi khác của
recol. Công thức như bạn nhìn thấy ở
đây. Được chưa? Còn cái khái niệm thứ
hai gọi là phone positive rate. Phone
positive rate nó bằng cái gì? Nó bằng
phone positive chia cho phone positive
cộng với true negative. Đây các bạn nh
cái ông đầu tiên thì là của cái hàng
đầu. Ông thứ hai của cái hàng hai này.
Được chưa? Thế nếu đây vẫn là bài toán
chó mèo mình coi con chó là cái class
positive đi đúng không? Thì true pot hay
là recolle nó là có nghĩa là gì? Nó có
nghĩa là tỉ lệ những con chó mình tìm
được thấy trong th trong thực tế đúng
không? Thế nếu vẫn là bài toán chó mèo
này thì theo các bạn là cái phot này nếu
mà mình mô tả bằng ngôn ngữ của con
người bằng tiếng Việt thì mình sẽ mô tả
như nào? Chó là positive, mèo là
negative. Thì ph ý nghĩa gì? Phone posit
nghĩa là gì?
Ý nghĩa là gì?
Nào
true potate nghĩa là tỉ lệ con chó mà
tôi tìm ra. For tỉ lệ gì tỷ lệ nhân ch
không chung chung quá tỉ lệ rửa đón chó
sai chung chung quá
chung chung quá
potate đấy ý nghĩa là gì
tỉ lệ gì
ờ đảo gà thành dương và chó thành âm à
hử
cái Cái gì cơ? Cái gì vàng? Cái gì?
Dương âm gì cơ?
Tỷ lệ gì nào?
Đây là tỉ lệ nói là trong tổng số các
con nó không phải là con chó thì cái
model nó đoán được đúng bao nhiêu phần
trăm
là không phải là con chó.
>> Có B nào có cách giải phần đơn giản hơn
[tiếng cười] không?
Nà đây mình thấy có hai bạn nào đúng
rồi. Các bạn Đắc Tín với cả bạn Nguyễn
Anh Dương này.
Tỷ lệ mèo mà bị nói thành chó thế thôi.
Tỷ lệ mèo bị nói thành chó hết đúng
không? Tỷ lệ mèo bị nói thành chó đúng
không? Mẫu là tổng số lượng mèo còn tử
là số lượng mèo mà bị nói thành chó hết
đúng không? Thế thôi đúng không? Tỉ lệ
mèo bị dự nó thành chó đó. Mình nói chó
mèo thôi đúng không? Thì các bạn nhìn
nhá. Các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ ấy, hai
cái true positive rate này và f positive
rate ấy, chúng nó lại muốn có mối quan
hệ gì? Chúng nó có một quan hệ là đồng
biến. Đồng biến có nghĩa là gì? Đồng
biến có nghĩa là hai ông này tăng cùng
tăng, giảm cùng giảm. Nó khác với lỗi
lại một với lỗi lại hai. Lỗi một với lỗi
lại hai là gì? Là một ông tăng, một ông
giảm, một ông giảm ông tăng hoặc là pion
rec là ông tăng ông giảm đúng không?
Nhưng mà hai ông này lại là tăng cùng
tăng và giảm cùng giảm. Được chưa? Đây
mình đang coi với bài toán là chỉ có chó
với mèo nhá. Cho đơn giản được chưa? Chỉ
có chó với mèo thôi. Được chưa? True
positive rate và full positive rate
chúng nó sẽ tăng cùng tăng giạp cùng
rap. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ tôi sẽ bằng
một cái việc là gì? Bây giờ tôi sẽ vẽ
lên hệ trục tọa độ de. Hệ Oxy đấy. Đúng
oxy đúng không? Trục hoành thì là f
positive rate, trục tung thì là true
positive rate. Thì bây giờ tôi mới làm
một cái việc này. Bây giờ tôi sẽ giả sử
đi cái điểm mà mô hình nó gắn cho cái
một cái input đầu vào nó sẽ một cái giá
trị nằm trong khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1 đi.
Được chưa? 0 cho đến 1 đúng không? Giá
trị dự đoán của mô hình nó sẽ nằm trong
khoảng từ 0 đến 1 thì có nghĩa là gì? Có
nghĩa là cái ngưỡng của bạn ấy các bạn
sẽ cũng chỉ có thể thay đổi từ 0 đến 1
thôi đúng không? Ví dụ như là điểm thi
đại học là từ 0 đến 30 thì điểm chuẩn
cũng chỉ có thể làm từ 0 đến 30 thôi.
Không thể nào mà dưới 0 không thể nào
trên 30 được đúng không? Thì đây nó cũng
như vậy đúng không? Cái điểm của mô hình
nó gắn s nó chỉ nằm khoảng từ 0 đến 1
thì cái dự đoán của mô hình nó cũng sẽ
chỉ có thể à cái ngưỡng các bạn chỉ từ 0
đến 1 thôi. Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ làm một
cái việc gì? Tôi sẽ lần lượt thay đổi
ngưỡng. Ngưỡng của tôi bắt đầu từ 0. Số
tôi cứ nhích dần lên rất là nhỏ thôi. 0
này 0,01 0,02 0,03 0,04 vân vân đến 0,98
0,99 là 1,0 đúng không? Tôi sẽ có 101
cái ngưỡng như vậy. Được chưa? Tôi sẽ
thay đổi 101 cái ngưỡng khác nhau. Và
bây giờ ấy với mỗi một cái ngưỡng mà tôi
vừa thay đổi ấy, với mỗi một cái ngưỡng
tôi sẽ tính xem là ở cái ngưỡng đó thì
true positive rate là bằng bao nhiêu và
f positive rate là bằng bao nhiêu. Được
chưa? với 101 cái ngưỡng từ 0 đến 1 đúng
không? 0 0,01 0,02 0,3 đến 0,98 0,9 0,
1,00 được chưa? 101 ngưỡng này tôi sẽ ở
tại mỗi cái ngưỡng tôi sẽ tính xem là ở
cái ngưỡng này precision bằng à xin lỗi
true positive rate bằng bao nhiêu f
positive rằ thì bằng bao nhiêu thì các
bạn thấy này f positive rate chính là
hoành độ còn true positive rate chính là
tung độ đúng không thì bây giờ với mỗi
cái ngưỡng đấy các bạn sẽ chấm một điểm
vào đây chấm một điểm đây đúng không xem
là hoành độ bằng bao nhiêu tung độ bằng
bao nhiêu đúng không thì các bạn có 101
cái ngưỡng thì các bạn cũng sẽ chấm được
101 cái điểm trên cái đồ thị này đúng
không? Trục hoành và trục tung đều chạy
từ 0 đến 1 đúng không? Tại vì là hai ông
này maximum cũng chỉ được một thôi đúng
không? Thế bây giờ sau khi tôi đã chấm
được 101 cái điểm như vậy rồi tôi sẽ nối
chút lại và với nhau và xư tô nối xong
tôi sẽ được cái đường màu vàng này. Cái
đường màu vàng là cái kết quả mà khi tôi
đã nối 101 cái điểm này lại với nhau sao
cho hai cái điểm cạnh nhau tôi sẽ nối
vào. Đúng không? Thế thế thì cái đường
này ấ cái đường này được gọi là đường
ROC. Đường này gọi là đường ROC.
Receiver đây. Tên như này. Tên đầy đủ
nhá. Tên tên đầy đủ như này.
Receiver
operating characteristic. Đây đường này
gọi là đường ROC. Được chưa? ROC là cái
đường màu vàng này. Đường màu vàng đây
này. Đấy là nó đấy. Đường màu vàng này.
Được chưa? Cái đường màu vàng này ấy nó
mà càng nằm thiên về góc trên cùng bên
trái càng càng nằm gần với cái điểm này.
Tức là nó càng gần cái điểm trên cùng
bên trái này thì cái mùn của các bạn nó
càng tốt.
Vì sao? Tại vì cái điểm trên cung bên
trái là cái điểm mà perfect là cái điểm
mà dán đúng 100% chả sai cái gì cả đúng
không? Đây cái chỗ mà true true pot bằng
1 và nó bằng 0 này đúng không? Thì cái
đường màu vàng này là cái đường ROC.
Nhìn trong cái đường RC này càng gần cái
điểm cấp trừng cùng bên trái thì nó càng
tốt. Được chưa? Thế cái đầu tiên đúng
không? Receiver operating characteristic
hay viết tắt là ROC. Được chưa?
Rồi có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì về cách
cái đường này được tạo ra không? Đường
ROC này
có bạn nào thắc mắc gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Không ai thắc mắc gì.
Mình chưa gặp một cái lớp nào mà không
thắc mắc gì về cái đường này đâu nhá.
Ví dụ vừa rồi đấy đúng không? Thì cũng
chó với mèo thôi. Chó với mèo đúng
không? Thế bây giờ có phải là cái mô
hình nó dự đoán chó với mèo đúng không?
Thì ví dụ lấy con chó là class positive
đi thì cái điểm của mô hình hoặc bây giờ
lấy ví dụ người bị Covid cho dễ đi đúng
không? Người bị Covid là class positive
được chưa? Thì bây giờ cái số điểm mô
hình nó gán cho một cái người sẽ là từ 0
đến 1 đúng không? Bình thường nếu mà cái
điểm nó trên 0,5 thì các bạn sẽ bảo là
người ta bị Covid. Dưới 0,5 thì các bạn
bảo là người ta bình thường đúng không?
Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ thay đổi giá trị
ngưỡng này đi. Tôi sẽ không cho nó là
0,5 nữa mà tôi sẽ đẩy xuống ví dụ tôi
cho nó bằng 0 đi. Đúng không các bạn?
Này bây giờ một cái mô hình mà giá người
bị Covid mà việc cái ngưỡng bằng 0 có
nghĩa là gì? Ngưỡng bằng 0 có nghĩa là
gì?
Ngưỡng bằng 0 có nghĩa là gì?
Ngưỡng mà không có nghĩa là gì? Đúng
rồi. Có nghĩa là ai cũng là bị Covid cả
đúng không? Ông
>> đúng rồi. Tức là ông nào tôi cũng bảo là
bị Covid. Được chưa? Xong tôi tăng dần
lên đúng không? Thì ngưỡ mà không như
vậy ấ đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ
không chỉ làm với một người, tôi sẽ làm
với tất cả.
Tôi sẽ làm với tất cả mọi người trong
cái bộ test thôi. Tôi có 1000 người đi
đúng không? 1000 người. Tôi sẽ làm hết
với 1000 người này xem là cuối cùng là
bây giờ trong 1000 người này đúng không?
Cái true positive rate là bằng bao
nhiêu? F positive rate bằng sẽ bằng bao
nhiêu? Đúng không? Các bạn cho mình hỏi
này. Trong trường hợp mà ngưỡng bằng 0
ấy thì nó sẽ tương ứng với cái điểm nào
trong cái đồ thị này?
Ngưỡng bằng 0 thì nó sẽ tương ứng với
cái điểm nào trong cái đồ thị này các
bạn?
ngưỡng bằng 0. Tức là ai tôi cũng bảo là
bị Covid cả thì nó sẽ tương ứng với cái
điểm nào?
Tương với cái điểm nào chính đưa cho cái
đồ thị này?
Dưới cùng bên phải á. Làm sao ở đây
được? Nó chỉ là cái đường màu vàng này
thôi. Làm sao dưới cùng bên phải được
rồi.
Nào gốc tọa độ hay là chia cùng bên phải
nào? Gốc tọa độ hay là chia cùng bên
phải?
Nào, gốc tọa độ hai chư cục cùng bên
phải.
Thế bây giờ thử tính nhá. Thử tính nhá.
Đúng không? Thế bây giờ ngũ bằng 0 có
nghĩa là ai chúng ta cũng bảo là người
ta bị Covid đúng không? Ông nào vào kiểm
tra 1000 ông tôi bảo cả 1000 ông đều bị
Covid cả. Thế thì lúc này cái true
positive rate bằng bao nhiêu các bạn?
Lúc này true positive rate là bằng bao
nhiêu? Bằng 1 đúng không? Tại vì bây giờ
tất cả những người bị Covid tôi đều tìm
ra cả đúng không? Thế lúc này phone
positive rate bằng bao nhiêu? Lúc này
phone positive rate bằng bao nhiêu?
Phone positive là tỉ lệ những người khỏe
mạnh mà tôi lại bảo là người ta bị Covid
đó cũng là một luôn. Đúng rồi. Cả hai
đều bằng một đúng không? Cả hai đều bằng
một nó sẽ là điểm góc chung cù bên phải.
Được chưa? Chù bên phải. Thế thế bây giờ
cái ngưỡng này các bạn sẽ tăng dần lên.
Ngưỡng tăng dần lên đúng không? Là 0 này
sang 0,01 0,02 0,03 tăng dần lên. Như
vậy thì mỗi khi bạn tăng cái ngưỡng vậy
ấ thì cái true positive rate và f
positive rate này nhìn chung chúng nó sẽ
giảm dần giảm dần giảm dần đúng không?
Và khi mà cái ngưỡng bằng 1 ngưỡng bằng
1 có nghĩa là gì? Ngưỡng bằng 1 có nghĩa
là ai tôi cũng bảo là khỏe cả đúng
không? Thì lúc này nó sẽ tương với cái
điểm 00 này đấy đúng không? Tức khi bạn
thay đổi cái ngưỡng nó sẽ là nó cứ từ
điểm góc trung ngù bên phải này số dần
điểm góc dương ngù bên trái đúng không
các bạn? Ngưỡng các bạn chia bao nhiêu
cũng được. Ví dụ các bạn chia là 0,1
0,02 các bạn sẽ có 101 điểm. Các bạn
chia là 0 0,001
0,002 các bạn sẽ có 1001 điểm. Tức các
bạn chia nhỏ bao nhiêu cũng được. Chia
càng nhỏ thì cái đường này nó càng chi
tiết nhưng mà nó sẽ càng lâu thôi. Được
chưa? Thì đây cách để người ta tạo ra
cái đường ROC này. Cứ tại một cái ngưỡng
các bạn sẽ tính xem là ở cái ngưỡng đấy
thì true positive rate bằng bao nhiêu?
Nó chính là trục tung ấy đúng không? Và
full positive rate bằng bao nhiêu nó
trục hoành. Được chưa? Có một cái điểm
các bạn có tọa độ là các bạn vẽ được cái
điểm đấy rồi đúng không? Sao các bạn nối
101 hoặc các bạn nối 1001 cái điểm này
lại với nhau các bạn được cái đường ROC
như này thế thôi.
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
>> Trên thực tế thì mình muốn mình muốn cái
điểm nó nằm ở đâu là tốt nhất.
>> Điểm nào ạ?
>> Chị vẫn chưa hiểu em mình vẽ cái này ha.
Chị vẫn chưa hiểu cái cái nối liên hệ
giữa hai cái ờ giữa hai cái trục tung
trục hoành. Tại sao mình lại chọn cái
matric, tại sao mình lại chọn cái chat
như vậy? Tại vì này
>> nó nó có ý nghĩa gì cái đường vàng ngoài
cái ý nghĩa về toán ra nó còn cái ý
nghĩa gì về thực tế? Cái ý nghĩa của nó
là gì? Là cái đường vàng này nó càng gần
cái đường góp trựng bên trái thì mô hình
nó càng tốt. Tại vì sao? Nó gần đây có
nghĩa là lỗi thì ít mà đúng thì nhiều.
Ví dụ cái điểm perfect là cái điểm góc
chung bên trái này là cái điểm gì? Là
cái điểm true pot rate nó bằng 1 và form
nó bằng 0 đúng không? Cái ông này là ông
đúng. Cái ông true là ông đúng, cái
formate là ông sai. Đấy thì cái điểm
perfect là cái điểm này. Thì cái đường
này mình cái xu hướng nó càng gần cái
điểm này thì nó càng tốt. Thì cái đường
này giúp mình có được cái góc nhìn toàn
cảnh về performance của mô hình trên
nhiều ngưỡng khác nhau thay vì chỉ có
một ngưỡng cụ thể như là các cái magic
như là accuracy rec hay là F1.
>> À ok.
>> Ví dụ là nó không là mình chỉ muốn là nó
đúng mà mình muốn là cái độ sai của nó
cũng sẽ nhỏ hơn.
>> Mình muốn cả hai thứ một lúc. Ờ tức
không phải tức tức tức tức là tức là này
hai cái ông này cái trục hoành ấy cái
trục hoành thì càng bé càng tốt còn trục
tung thì càng to càng tốt. Thế nhưng mà
vấn đề là hai ông này nó lại đồng biến.
Đồng biến tức là tăng cùng tăng giảm
cùng giảm. Đấy kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thế
nên là bây giờ tôi phải tìm tức là tôi
muốn có cái góc nhìn toàn cảnh này để
sau này tôi sẽ chọn xem là cái đây đâu
là cái chỗ mà tôi sẽ tôi sẽ chọn đúng
không? Tại vì là
tại vì là một ông là tốt, một ông là tồi
nhưng mà tăng giảm cùng nhau thì mình sẽ
phải chọn tể cho xem cái chỗ nào là cái
chỗ mà tôi có cái ví dụ tôi có cái true
rate nó là tốt nhất mà trong khi phone
nó đủ bé kiểu kiểu như vậy. Đúng rồi.
Mình muốn cái tổng quan ở nhiều ngưỡng
tại vì này aqua cion col f1 nó chỉ cho
mình nhìn ở một ngưỡng thôi. Mình có 100
ngưỡng thì mình sẽ có 100 cái bộ này
nhìn nó chỉ toàn là con số nhìn nó sẽ
khó. Tôi muốn có một cái bức tranh như
này cái đường màu vàng này nó có cái
xuống nó càng lệch trên góc trên cù bên
trái thì mô hình mình tôi của tôi là về
mặt tổng quát nó càng tốt. Tức là nó tốt
trên nhiều ngưỡng chứ không phải thì tốt
ở một cái ngưỡng cụ thể.
>> Ừ.
>> Thế cái ngưỡng đấy nhá thì nó chỉ là một
cái factor một cái nhân tố mình chọn
thôi phải không?
>> Thế bây giờ nếu mình chọn nhiều nhân tố
khác nhau thì nó như thế nào?
>> Mình không chọn được. Mình không được.
>> Ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ như là nói chuyện chó
mèo đi. Ví dụ như chị chị ví dụ như con
đ em pí một con một con có lông thì nó
có thể là vừa là chó vừa là mèo. Nhưng
mà một con không lông thì nhiều khả năng
là con chó
>> phải không?
>> Hình như ờ
>> cái mô hình của mình nó sẽ bẻ ra một cái
số điểm cuối cùng giống kiểu này thi đại
học có ba môn toàn lý hóa. Ví dụ khối A
toàn lý hóa. Có thể ông này điểm này ca
điểm kia thất nhưng mà cuối cùng tôi
phải có một cái số điểm cuối cùng. Tức
là tôi phải có một cái con số cuối cùng.
Tức là dù là chó mèo tôi phải có một cái
gì cuối cùng. cái hồ sơ bệnh án của bệnh
nhân tôi có thể là tôi có cả nước tiểu,
tôi có máu, tôi có huyết áp, tôi có điện
tâm đồ, tôi có gì nhưng đến cuối tôi
phải có một cái số điểm cuối cùng phải
có một cái final score và chúng ta sẽ
làm việc với cái final score đó.
>> Thế thế tức là trước khi ra đến cái
final score đó thì mình có cái weight à
mình cho lên mỗi một cái
>> tức là mình có thể mình có thể có một
cái gì đấy tại vì là cái dưng cuối cùng
mình nó chỉ là một cái con số thôi. Cuối
cùng dưng mình nó chỉ là một cái con số.
Thế còn có thể trước đấy nó sẽ có nhiều
cái factor đấy thì có thể là ok ví dụ là
cái factor này thì tôi quan trọng hay
cái ít quan trọng thì nó sẽ có đấy là
cái việc của mô hình tức là bản thân
những cái mô hình trong machining nó sẽ
làm cái việc đấy nó sẽ làm việc xem là
ông nào quan trọng nó sẽ ảnh hưởng nhiều
đến kết quả nào ít thế giống như kiểu là
sư đi thi toán lý hóa ví dụ cái toán văn
anh toán lý hóa mà toán điểm nhân đôi
đấy kiểu kiểu như vậy ta toán là môn
quan trọng tôi sẽ nh nhân nhân đôi còn
lý hóa nó ít quan trọng tôi sẽ để một
thôi kiểu kiểu kiểu kiểu như vậy đấy
thế thì sau cái nhân đôi cái cái cụm từ
nhân đôi đấy đằng sau đó cũng là một cái
mô hình nhỏ phải không? Làm sao người ta
biết được là toán phải nhân đôi mà không
phải văn nhân đôi. Vậy ý ý chị là để để
được cái để tính
>> đúng rồi thế đấy là nhiệm vụ cái đúng
rồi đấy nhiệm vụ cái thật toán machining
thì những buổi sau mình sẽ học xem là
mỗi thật toán nó sẽ có kiểu khác nhau.
>> Có thật toán này nó sẽ làm theo kiểu là
nó cộng trừ.
>> Có thật toán lại làm theo kiểu nó so
sánh giòn nó lại kiểu góm nhóm. Đấy tức
là mỗi cái nó sẽ có một cái factor khác
như thế thì những buổi sau thì mình sẽ
đi qua dần.
>> Ừ.
Ok. Thế từ ROC này thì mình biết cái
ngưỡng nào là tốt nhất ý là về lý thuyết
là càng gần true positive và càng à tr
positive càng cao hoặc và positive càng
bé càng tốt. Nhưng mà đều có công thức
nào để đánh giá?
>> Mình sẽ không có. Mình sẽ không có tại
vì như mình nói rồi có những bài toán nó
cần recall bài toán nó cần pression thì
mới b toàn nó sẽ có cái khác nó sẽ có
cái khác nhau chứ mình sẽ không có một
cái kết quả chung đâu. Nó sẽ không có
kết quả chung. Tại vì nếu có thì nếu có
thì cần gì phải vẽ cái đường này. Nếu có
thì người ta lấy luôn cái kết quả đấy là
được rồi. Đúng không? Mỗi bài toàn nó sẽ
có cái ưu tiên khác nhau.
Mỗi bài toàn nó sẽ cái ưu tiên khác
nhau. Chúng ta sẽ không có một cái đúng
không? Có cái chung ấy thì dễ quá rồi.
Có cái chung đấy thì dễ quá rồi. Cần gì
phải làm đèn thí nữa đúng không? Cứ lấy
ốp số vào là xong đúng không? [khịt mũi]
Đúng rồi. Cái trục tung ấy càng cần một
càng tốt. Trục hoành càng gần không thì
càng thì càng tốt.
Chị muốn hỏi cái precision nó thể hiện ở
đâu? Trên cái cái trái cái này thì nó
lại không có precision hay là không có.
Không có.
>> Ừ.
>> Thế cái đường đỏ là cái gì đấy?
>> À đường đỏ. Đường đỏ là đường đỏ người
ta minh họa là một cái mô hình random,
một cái mô hình mà trung bình cứ hai dự
đoán lại đúng một. Một cái mô hình mà
trung bình cứ hai dự án lại đúng một thì
nó sẽ là cái mô hình có cái đường màu đỏ
này. Cái đường màu đỏ trên cái đường ROC
của cái mô hình random đấy. Thế thì bây
giờ ấy cái mô hình tốt là cái mô hình nó
phải cách xa cái đường này vài nằm cách
lên lên trên. Cách càng xa thì mô hình
càng tốt. Tại vì cái mô hình random tôi
là mô hình nó chả học cái gì cả. Nó cứ
hai ông nó nó dự ấn ông nào cũng dự ấn
ngẫu nhiên thì cứ dự ấn chung ngẫu nhiên
lại trung bình cứ hai ông lại đúng một.
Đấy thì cái đường cái mô hình tốt là cái
mô hình mà có cái đường màu vàng càng
gần cái điểm góp trung cù bên trái càng
tốt và càng cách xa cái đường màu đỏ
càng tốt. Cách xa theo cái hướng là cách
xa lên trên nhá chứ còn cách xa mà ở
dưới nó có là tồi hơn cả mô hình random.
Đấy.
>> Thế nếu như mình đánh giá tổng quát thì
theo như theo dện tích giữa cái phần màu
vàng và cái phần đường đỏ
>> à vâng đúng rồi. Đây
>> sắc nó càng to thì nó càng to không?
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác chính xác. Chính là
như thế. Thì tĩa mình sẽ nói đến cái mic
thứ hai. Đúng rồi. Thế các bạn nhìn này
nhá. Các bạn không ờ chị chị lưu vừa nói
là gì? Là các bạn nhìn này, cái đường
màu vàng này ấy nó có một cái nhược điểm
là gì? Cái đường màu vàng cái ưu điểm
của nó là gì? Cái đường màu vàng có ưu
điểm là giúp chúng ta có cái bức tranh
toàn cảnh về performance của mô hình
trên nhiều ngưỡng khác nhau. Nó giống
như kiểu này bây giờ nhá. Thi ba môn là
30 điểm. Bây giờ tôi muốn có một bức
tranh ảnh là gì? Là nếu bây giờ tôi thay
đổi cái điểm sàn ấy từ 0 đến 30 điểm thì
cái tỉ lệ đỗ trượt nó như nào? Đấy tức
là bây giờ tôi thay đổi tôi sẽ góp đường
này tôi sẽ biết cái góc nhìn toàn cảnh.
Tức là ok điểm này tôi sẽ lấy được bao
nhiêu sinh viên, điểm kia lấy được bao
nhiêu. Thế nhưng mà cái đường màu vàng
có một cái nhược điểm là gì? Là nó không
có thứ nguyên, nó không có đơn vị. Ví dụ
bây giờ tôi có ba mô hình đi. Tôi có ba
mô hình thì ba mô hình tôi mỗi mô hình
nó sẽ có một cái một cái đường ROC này.
Thế các bạn cứ tưởng tượng nhá, bình
thường đi các bạn so đánh bằng accuracy
prion reconnect one đúng không? Các bạn
có con số cụ thể. Ví dụ mô hình A có
aquasi là 70%, mô hình B có aquac là 72%
thì rõ ràng 72 tốt hơn 70. Thế nhưng mà
bây giờ các bạn có hai cái đường hai mô
hình, mỗi mô hình có một cái đường này.
Cái đường của ông A thì ở cái khúc này
nó tốt hơn ông B nhưng mà cái mô hình
của ông B ở cái khúc kia lại tốt hơn ông
A. Thì bây giờ có hai cái đường này ấy
thì thực sự là rất là khó để có thể so
sánh được hai cái đường ROC với nhau.
Cho bạn một cái ví dụ nhá. Đây này.
Đây nhá. Cho bạn ví dụ này khi bạn có
nhiều cái đường RC nó như thế này đấy
các bạn thấy không một mả đúng không làm
sao mà so được đúng không làm sao mà so
so rất là khó đúng không rất là khó để
các bạn có thể so sánh được hai cái
đường RC này về với nhau đúng không tại
vì đ này đúng không có chỗ thì ông này
tốt hơn có chỗ ông kia tốt hơn thì so
kiểu gì bây giờ thế thì bây giờ người ta
mới làm một cái việc là gì là bây giờ
thay vì tôi so sánh hai cái ông không có
đơn vị đúng không hai cái đường này
đường này làm gì có đơn vị đâu làm gì có
con số đâu thì bây giờ tôi sẽ tính cái
phần diện tích được tạo ra bởi cái đường
ROC này với trục hoành
nhá. Tôi sẽ tính cái phần diện tích được
tạo ra đên này với trục hoành thì rõ
ràng là cái đường nào mà có cái diện
tích này lớn hơn thì về mặt tổng quát nó
sẽ tốt hơn đúng không? Diện tích này nó
nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1 tại vì gì?
Hoành độ cũng chỉ từ 0 đến 1 mà tung độ
cũng từ 0 đến 1. Thế nên là cái diện
tích này cũng chỉ từ 0 đến 1 thôi. Thì
bây giờ người ta sẽ là gì? Người ta sẽ
tính cái diện tích dưới cái đường này
thì người ta gọi là gì? Err là diện tích
đúng không? R under the curve hay là gì?
AUC. Được chưa? R under ROC curve hay ta
viết là AUC R diện tích đúng không?
Under là ở bên dưới đúng không? Diện
tích ở bên dưới cái đường màu vàng này
đúng không? Diện tích này càng lớn thì
nhìn chung là mô hình nó tổng quát nó
càng tốt được chưa? Thì bây giờ thay vì
tôi phải so sánh hai cái đường mà tôi
cũng không biết là tôi so bằng cái gì
bây giờ thì tôi sẽ so cái phần diện tích
được đè ở phía dưới chúng nó tạo bởi v
trục hành được chưa? Là auc AUC thì có đ
tí đúng không thì thì nó là con số AOC
là con số đúng không? Thì các bạn sẽ
xoánh được hai ông với nhau thôi. Được
chưa?
Trong thực tế người ta sẽ ít khi người
ta vẽ một cái đường riêng lẻ sẽ vẽ có
khi một cái biểu đồ ta vẽ năm sáu đường
mỗi đường liên quan đến một mô hình. Thì
bây gi sánh xem là về tổng quát thì mô
hình nào tốt hơn tôi sẽ dùng AUC đúng
không? Ông nào có phần diện tích lớn
nhất thì là ông đấy tốt nhất thôi. Được
chưa?
Rồi
nào có câu hỏi gì không
nhá? Đây là hai magic nâng cao. Các bạn
mới đầu thì các bạn với những cái magic
như là Aquac V1 thì các bạn bắt buộc các
bạn phải hiểu. Thế còn
AU ROC với AOC thì à các bạn hiểu được
ngay thì tốt còn không thì không sao.
Trong quá trình học các bạn chúng ta sẽ
dùng dần chúng ta sẽ vỡ ra thôi nhá. Thì
đây là hai cái magric giúp các bạn có
thể đánh giá được hoặc là có được cái
góc nhìn tổng quan về cái performance m
của hình trên nhiều ngưỡng. Được chưa?
Ngưỡng là cái gì? Ngưỡng là cái điểm
phân biệt giữa class này với class kia
đúng không? Ngưỡng ví dụ ngày xưa thi
đại học, ngưỡng là cái điểm sàn đấy.
Trên sàn thì là đỗ đại học mà dưới sàn
là trượt đại học đúng không? Đấy. Cái
đây cũng thế.
Rồi
có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Có có thắc mắc gì không?
Nào thầ nhìn kỹ xem nào. Tất cả những
cái magri này có cái gì các bạn thấy con
chưa clear, chưa rõ ràng không? Acuracy
rec là những giá trị từng ngưỡng đúng
không? Đổi ngưỡng một cái là phải ngồi
tính lại từ đầu. Còn đây là cái góc nhìn
tổng qua trên nhiều ngưỡng với nhau.
Dạ anh ơi.
>> Ừ. Nếu em hỏi lại một lần nữa cho nó
chắc chưa? Nếu mà cái bài toán này của
mình đó là dự đoán người bị Covid
>> ừ
>> thì bị Covid sẽ là positive
>> đúng
>> còn không bị sẽ là negative.
>> Đúng.
>> Thì nếu như mà mình cho là tất cả mọi
người đều bị Covid hết
>> ừ
>> thì cái ngưỡng của mình nó sẽ là một.
Thì cái thằng ý em là ngưng phải là
không chứ. Ngưỡng phải là không chứ.
Trên không là bị Covid, dưới không là bị
đấy đúng không? Thì điểm nằm ở trên
không đúng không? Ngưỡng phải là không
chứ. Thì tức là to positive red của mình
nó sẽ là cái điểm ở trên cùng bên tay
phải
>> đúng.
>> Còn f positive red nó sẽ là cái điểm
>> cũng có dù bên phải luôn. Nó là một điểm
mà.
>> Dạ đúng rồi. Nó là một điểm
>> đúng không? Nó chỉ là một điểm thôi đúng
không? Hoành độ bằng 1 tung độ bằng 1
luôn. Được chưa?
thì cái thì cái ngưỡng của mình nó sẽ là
không
>> đúng phải là từ ngưỡng mới ra được hai
kia phải từ ngưỡng mới ra được hai ông
kia chứ không thể từ hai ông kia lại ra
ngưỡng được không ngưỡng là cái suy ra
hai ông này ngưỡng là cái phải có ngưỡng
đã so mới ra được true 4 giống như kiểu
là phải có điểm sàn thì mới biết ông nào
đỗ ông nào trượt chứ đúng không
còn nếu mà ở cái điểm hoành độ là 0 tung
độ cũng là 0
>> ừ
>> thì tức là ngưỡng của mình nó sẽ là 1.
Chính xác. Chính xác. Đúng rồi. Chính là
như thế.
Đúng rồi. Tức là gì? Tức là ông nào vào
tôi cũng bảo là khỏe cả.
Đúng rồi. Cái RC không nhìn vào RC biết
ông ngữ nào là ngữ tối ưu được. Nó chỉ
chúng ta có cái góc nhìn toàn cảnh thôi.
Thông thường người ta sẽ có một vài cái
mẹo ta làm thế này. Tức là gì? Bây giờ
ấy có một cái mẹo này là gì? người ta
xem là từ cái điểm góp chung bên trái
người ta sẽ vẽ những cái hình bán nguyệt
xem là nó bắt đầu nó tiếp xúc với cái
đường này ở đâu thì cái điểm đấy sẽ
người ta có thể coi đ là là điểm tối ưu
đúng không? T đây các bạn sẽ vẽ những
cái hình tròn to dần to dần to dần thì
khi nào nó tiếp xúc ở đây ở cái điểm nào
thì đấy là cái điểm tối ưu thì các bạn
sẽ từ cái điểm đấy các bạn phải suy
ngược xem là cái điểm này nó tương bị
ngưỡng là bao nhiêu. Được chưa?
Mình chỉ nói là nó cho chúng ta cái góc
nhìn toàn cảnh thôi chứ mình không bảo
là nhìn vào cái điểm này các bạn sẽ xét
ra được ngưỡng đúng không? cho mình cái
nhìn toàn cảnh thôi.
>> Anh ơi, cái ngưỡng ấy thì nó chỉ là một
cái tiêu chuẩn để mình
>> đúng giá nó là cái thứ phân cách giữa
class này và class kia.
>> Vâng. Đấy, cái mô hình để nó biết được
khi nào là positive còn khi nào là
negative thôi đúng không anh?
>> Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Nó ngưỡ nó giống
kiểu
>> dữ liệu thì nó vẫn để im thế. Còn dữ
liệu mình không có
>> ừ đúng rồi. Dữ liệu chả có gì đổi cả.
Vẫn là cái bài kiểm tra đấy đúng không?
Bây giờ điểm điểm sàn là 12 điểm tăng
lên 13 14 15 thì sẽ có ông từ đỗ đành
chưa? Từ chưa đánh đỗ kiểu như vậy.
>> Vâng. Em cảm ơn anh.
>> Ừ.
>> Dạ anh ơi.
>> Ờ khi mà mình chọn ngưỡng á thì cái
khoảng cái cái bước nhảy của ngưỡng á
thì nếu như mà cái bức nhảy nó quá gần
nhau thì cái đường của mình nó có thành
một cái đường mà nó kiểu nó nó kiểu nó
nó cong hay là thay vì nó nó thay vì nó
kiểu step như kiểu này không anh?
>> Các bạn mà chọn cái điểm các cái cái mức
độ chia nó càng nhỏ. Ví dụ nhá, các bạn
chia là 0,01
0,002 các bạn chia nhỏ vậy thì cái đường
bạn nó sẽ càng mượt. Nó sẽ càng mượt.
>> Đúng rồi, nó sẽ càng mượt nhưng mà cái
thời tính toán sẽ càng lâu. Còn các bạn
chia ngưỡng bé, các bạn chia ngưỡng lớn
ví dụ là 0,0 này, 0,01 0,02 chia ngưng
lớn thì cái nó sẽ nhìn nó sẽ rích rắc
hơn như này. Đây nhìn nó sẽ gồ ghề nó sẽ
kiểu khúc khửu khúc khu khửu này. Đấy
nhưng mà nó sẽ nhanh hơn. Đấy thì các
bạn chia càng nhỏ, các bạn chia nó càng
chi tiết thì nó đường nó càng mượt mà
các bạn chia cái khoảng nó càng lớn thì
nó càng khúc khỉu thôi. Còn nếu mà được
ý em là nếu như mà kiểu hai cái đường mà
nó đều mượt thì cái việc tính toán diện
tích thì nó có ảnh hưởng đến nhau không
anh? Ví dụ kiểu cái đường này mượt hơn
thì cái diện tích nó sẽ bé hơn đường kia
chẳng hạn.
>> Không không không. Cái mượt đấy nó không
ảnh hưởng đâu. Nó chỉ đơn giản là cái
phần diện tích nó tạo bởi vì cái phần
dưới này thôi chứ cái mượt hay không
mượt hay không mượt hay là khúc khỉu nó
chỉ phụ thuộc vào cái việc các bạn chia
nhỏ hay là chia lớn. Thế còn nó sẽ không
biến từ một cái mô hình tốt mô hình tồi
đâu. Mô hình nó mô hình nó đã tốt rồi.
Các bạn chia khoảng nhỏ ha chia khoảng
lớn nó vẫn cứ là mô hình tốt. Còn mô
hình mà nó đã tồi rồi thì các bạn có
chia nhỏ hay chia bé nó vẫn cứ là mô
hình tổi.
>> Chị chị hỏi nhá. Cái em nói chuyện chia
ngưỡng phải không?
>> Thế thì thế có những cái mô hình em có
thể chia ngưỡng mà gọi là
>> continuousọ tiếng Việt gọi là cái gì?
Liên tục ví dụ như điểm số nhá. Điểm số
nhá đúng không? Em có thể nói là bạn
trượt bạn trượt bạn đỗ thì là 10 15 điểm
14,9 14,8 14,82 đúng không? Nhưng đấy
đấy là cái gọi là những cái ngưỡng nó có
thể gọi là liên tục và infinite không
không có số nhưng có những cái ví dụ như
Covid chẳng hạn mình đâu có infinite đâu
đúng không? Cái ngưỡng của mình mình chỉ
có thể nói là â người này bị sốt cao,
người này bị ơ sốt, người này bị sốt
trên 38 độ, dưới 38 độ, người này bị hắt
xì hơi không hát xì hơi, người này đấy
kim kiểu như thế thì theo chị là có thể
theo chị là cái ngưỡng mà em nói đó thì
không phải theo chị mà ý chị muốn hỏi là
cái ngưỡng mà em nói thì phải tùy vào
cái cái bài toán mình đang xác định em
có thể có những cái ngưỡng
>> không liên tục à disc và continuous phải
không? Thì có cái cách nào gọi là aconiz
gọi là để cho nó
vâng tức là tức là ấy cái góc nhìn của
mô hình nó sẽ không giống góc nhìn con
người đúng tức là con người chúng ta tức
là với bài toán liên quan đến điểm nó sẽ
một kiểu, liên quan đến người một kiểu.
Thế nhưng mà với mô hình ấy tất cả nó
đều quy ra số cả. Tức là với cái hồ sơ
bệnh án của bệnh nhân đấy tức là dựa
theo cái số liệu về nhịp tim, về nước
tiểu, về máu, về tố đồ các thứ ấy nó sẽ
ra một cái output là một cái số điểm cho
bệnh nhân này. Tất cả nó sẽ quy về số.
Tại vì máy móc nó đâu có hiểu chữ đâu.
Tất cả nó sẽ quy về số. Input nó cũng sẽ
đưa về số và output nó cũng sẽ đưa về
số. Thì tóm lại là cái số điểm mà nó sẽ
tạo nó sẽ đưa ra một cái số điểm cho cái
người này. Đấy. Và chúng ta sẽ phải
soanh cái số điểm này với một cái ngưỡng
nào đó. Thế cái ngưỡng đấy thì chúng ta
vẫn có thể liên tục. Tại vì là mô hình
nó đâu? Mô hình nó không khe đây là dữ
liệu về cái gì. Nó chỉ biết là tôi làm
việc với dữ liệu dạng số và tôi cũng sẽ
giao cho nó cũng là số. Nó không khe đây
là dữ liệu về bệnh nhân hay là dữ liệu
về điểm của học sinh. Nó chỉ biết là gì?
Tôi nhận một cái vecơ đổ vào là vecơ về
số và tôi sẽ ra một cái số điểm cũng là
số luôn.
Thế cái cái cái số đó nó có thể thay đổi
theo
ờ
cái chị type của data cùng một typ và
data nhưng mà nó có thể thay đổi theo
thời điểm khác nhau có thể khác nhau
phải không? Vâng, đúng rồi, đúng rồi,
đúng rồi. Cùng một bệnh nhân đấy, hôm
nay nó sẽ ra một số điểm khác, ngày mai
ra một số điểm khác. Giữa bệnh nhân A,
bệnh nhân B chắc là cũng có số điểm
khác. Đúng rồi, cứ mỗi lần input đầu vào
mà thay đổi thì nhìn chung cái out đầu
ra nó cũng sẽ thay đổi theo.
Thì với tất cả các cái bài toán phân
loại, chúng ta đều quy về cái việc là
gì? Là mô hình nó sẽ gắn điểm. Và thật
ra về mặt bản chất đúng là mô hình nó
gán điểm thật. Mô hình nó sẽ luôn gắn
một cái số điểm. nó sẽ không ra một cái
kết quả tuyệt đối là bị này hay là bị
kia 1 hay là 0 mà nó sẽ ra một cái số
điểm nào đấy. Và khi mà chúng ta ra cái
kết quả là chúng ta do chúng ta đã so
cái số điểm đấy với cái ngưỡng rồi.
Giống kiểu là bây giờ ờ bảo của bạn là
trượt hay đỗ ấy. Thật ra lúc bạn chị đại
học các bạn không có kết quả trượt hay
đỗ mà các bạn sẽ có một cái số điểm và
số điểm đấy người ta đem so với cái điểm
sàn người ta mới bảo là các bạn chưa
thay đỗ. Thế đây nó cũng y chang như
vậy.
>> Em hỏi một câu đúng không anh? Ừ. Hỏi
thoải mái. Hỏi thoải mái.
>> Nó quay lại cái bài toán Covid vừa nãy á
là nó dự đoán là
>> nguy cơ bị Covid là như thế nào ấy thầy.
>> Đúng rồi. Nói là nguy cơ thì sẽ chính
xác hơn. Đúng rồi. Nó sẽ là nguy cơ đi.
Đúng rồi. Thay vì nói là Covid nó sẽ là
nguy cơ và khi nguy cơ này nó trên
ngưỡng thì mình bảo là bị Covid. Đúng
rồi. Ok. Ngại bài này bạnạ. Nguy cơ hợp
lý. Rồi
>> thế em hỏi một tí là
nó có biết được nó có dự đoán được là
khi nào nguy cơ nó xảy ra không thầy?
>> Ờ không mô hình nó sẽ phù hợp với cái
rượu có đánh nhãn chúng ta. Tức là dữ
liệu chúng ta nó chỉ có cái thông tin về
việc là là bị hay không thôi thì mô hình
nó chỉ làm được như vậy thôi đúng không?
Nếu mà chúng ta đi cho nó cái dữ liệu là
thời điểm bị Covid thì có thể nó sẽ làm
được. Có thể nó sẽ làm được. Tức là nó
phụ thuộc vào là cái dữ liệu chúng ta
đưa nó cái gì. Nếu giống kiểu con người
cũng thế thôi. Chúng ta đưa một quyển
sách cho một đứa học sinh nó chỉ có đạo
hàm thì nó chỉ biết tính đạo hàm thôi.
Đưa quyển sách đến tích phân nó sẽ tính
tích phân thôi chứ không thể đưa quyển
sách về kiến thức này bắt nó làm kiến
thức kia được đúng không?
Bởi vì á em thấy là cái RC này thứ em
cũng làm nhiều về RC này.
>> Ừ
>> thì em thấy là nó các cái sự kiện nào mà
nó nó liên quan đến thời gian ấy
>> à casting
>> làm được.
>> Ừ.
>> Tức là ví dụ như bây giờ anh nói là chú
có sốt thì nguy cơ là có bị Covid hay
không thì là nó làm được.
>> Ừ.
>> Nhưng mà nó không biết là với cái sốt
này thì nguy khi nào thì sẽ bị Covid thì
nó không biết.
>> Ừ. Bởi vì trong cái công thức để làm RC
này thì
>> nó không gắn với thời gian.
>> Đúng. Và cái input độ vào mình cũng
không có thời gian. Nếu mà có yếu tố
thời gian nó sẽ ra bình toán time c
forcasting. Tức là tôi theo dõi liên tục
và bệnh nhân đúng không? Ví dụ là cứ một
ngày tôi lại đo một lần hoặc là cứ một
tiếng tôi đo một lần đúng không? Thì đấy
là bài đán time c forcasting. Tức là gì?
Tôi dự đoán về giá trị hiện tại dựa vào
những cái thứ đã xảy ra trong quá khứ
nhá.
Bản thân cái mô hình này khi chúng ta
đưa rượu vào nó cũng không có thông tin
gì và thời gian. Tôi chỉ biết là ông này
có những cái chỉ số như thế còn cụ thể
đo vào lúc nào lúc vào sáng tối tôi
không có biết
bởi vì em có một cái bài toán là à ví dụ
như thời điểm hôm nay đi là em có 100
bệnh nhân đến khám chẳng hạn.
>> Ừ
>> thì có bệnh nhân có sốt này, có bệnh
nhân có dụ hôi sổ mũi này, chảy mũi này,
rồi các xét nghiệm về sinh hóa này thế
kia.
>> Ừ. Ừ.
>> Nhưng mà có những bệnh nhân thì 3 ngày
sau người ta mới dương tính cơ. Có những
bệnh nhân thì 5 ngày cơ.
>> Ừ.
>> Bệnh nhân một tuần sau.
>> Ừ. Nhưng nếu mà dùng cái RC này ấ thì
cái yếu tố thời gian là sẽ bị omit. Đúng
chính xác.
Thế nếu mình mình muốn cái mô hình nó dự
như vậy, một cái mô hình nó có thể hoàn
toàn nó vừa dự đoán xem là bệnh nhân có
bị bệnh hay không và nó có thể dự đoán
được là cái thời gian phát bệnh là bao
giờ. Nhưng với điều kiện là gì? là cái
rượa đồ vào chúng ta cho nó cũng phải có
thông tin đấy. Tức là nếu mình có rượu
đồ vào là một cái dữ liệu vừa chỉ ra là
một bệnh nhân có bị bệnh hay không và
vừa chỉ ra là nếu có bị bệnh thì bị vào
thời điểm nào thì mô hình nó sẽ hoàn
toàn làm được như vậy. Và cái mô hình
này nó sẽ là mô hình nó live giữa hai
bài toán. Nó live giữa classification và
regression. Tức là cùng một cái base nó
ra hai cái đầu, hai cái header. Một cái
header cho classification là có bị bệnh
hay không. một cái header là regression
tức là bao nhiêu ngày nữa bao nhiêu ngày
ủ bệnh kiểu kiểu như vậy thì đối với nó
sẽ là một mô hình nhưng mà cho hai bài
toán thì đôi bên để đánh giá nó sẽ phải
dùng hai cái magri khác nhau
nhưng mà với điều kiện là gì là cái dựa
đầu vào nó cũng phải có có thông tin đấy
chúng ta muốn mình nó làm cái gì thì dựa
đầu vào nó cũng phải có đúng thông tin
đấy thì nó mới làm được
>> th nếu mà em có thời gian thời kiểu thời
gian tái phát của các bệnh nhân ấy thì
nó cũng sẽ học được đúng không thầy
>> cũng có thể ừ đúng rồi thế dùng m nó sẽ
học được đấy mình lúc ấy mình cho vào
mấy mình mới dễ huấn luyện nó coi như là
coi như là huấn luyện có thể coi như là
huấn luyện hai bài toán đi. Hai bài toán
hai mô hình riêng biệt đi. Một mô hình
là chỉ dự đoán là có bị bệnh hay không
và một cái mô hình dự đoán là thời gian
ủ bệnh là bao nhiêu. Khi mình kết hợp
kết quả lại thì xong đúng không? Nếu mà
không bị bệnh thì thôi không dùng. Nếu
ông đầu tiên bảo không bị bệnh thì không
dùng đến ông thứ hai. Còn ông đầu tiên
bảo bị bệnh là tôi sẽ nói ra ông cái ông
thứ hai là bao nhiêu ngày nữa thì nó bị
mạnh.
Hình như là hồi xưa em cũng từng làm bài
toán time series rồi
>> thì em có nhớ một lần đó là em kiểu em
làm là em sẽ cũng kết hợp hai model như
anh nói nó tạo thành một cái hybrid
model
>> tức là mỗi cái nó sẽ sẽ xử lý một công
việc riêng.
>> Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Sa kết hợp lại với
nhau. Nó giống như này ạ. Sau này nhá
bạn nào mà các bạn học tiếp lên cái khóa
trên ấ các bạn học về mảng computer
vision giống như mình đang làm ấy. Các
bạn thấy là trong computer vision nó có
một cái bài toán cũng y chang như vậy.
Nó kết hợp giữa hai bài toán là bài toán
object detection. Objection là gì đây
các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây trên đây mình vừa
mình vừa mới làm đây mình làm cho một
bên a bên tỉnh ủy gì ấy nhở tỉnh ủy cái
gì Đồng Nai đây nhá cái này làm đếm các
bạn nhìn nhá đây vừa mới làm xong
cái này thật ra không phải objection cái
này nó là không đây là setation rồi đây
cái này trước cơ đây nhá các bạn nhìn
này đây là bài toán phát hiện đối tượng
một đối tượng đây nó là con bò được chưa
thì nó sẽ có kết hợp của hai bài toán
một là bài toán regression regression là
gì là phát hiện cái vị trí của con bò.
Được chưa? Đây là regression. Bài toán
thứ hai là bài toán classification.
Classification tại vì sao? Tôi chỉ ra
đây là con bò chứ không phải con chó
đúng không? Đấy là bài toán
classification. Đây là kết hợp giữa hai
bài toán này. Được chưa?
Nếu lấy ngưỡng là 0 và trên 0 là người
bị covid mẫu là 1000 người. Nếu lấy
ngưỡng là 0 và trên 0. Ngưỡng thì chỉ có
một thôi. Ngưỡng thì chỉ có một thôi. Và
ngưỡng là không thì chị phom bao nhiêu
thì phải dự đoán mình phải có cái dự
đoán và cái dây thực tế chứ đúng không?
1000 người này có bao nhiêu người là
thực sự là người ta bị Covid và dự đoán
có một nêu từng người là bao nhiêu thì
lúc đây tôi mới tính được chứ chứ có mỗi
cái ngưỡng là sao mà tính được. Bây giờ
mình có mỗi một cái chỉ số là gì? Mình
có 100 sinh viên đi thi, 100 học sinh đi
thi. Mình bảo là điểm sàn là 12 điểm.
Biết mỗi điểm sàn về biết tổng số lượng
sinh viên đi thi là làm sao mà tính
được. Phải xem là cụ thể từng ông được
bao nhiêu điểm thì luôn mới có cái để so
sánh chứ đúng không? Chứ làm sao mà dựa
vào ngưỡng phả dựa vào số lượng mẫu mà
biết được là cụ thể giá trị là bao nhiêu
được.
Nào có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì nữa không
anh ơi? Ừ
>> cái con bò hồi nãy anh mà mà anh nói á
>> ừ
>> hồi xưa em nhớ em có học cái môn
computer vision thì nó sẽ có nhiều cái
mạng [hắng giọng] liên quan đến computer
vision ví dụ như là kiểu như là
cmentation hay là object detection
>> thì các bài hồi nãy mà anh nói nó gồm
những cái bài toán nào trong đó anh
>> nó bao gồm bài toán nó chỉ bài toán
chính bài toán object detection sau thêm
một bài toán object tracking tracking để
theo dõi con bò đấy để tránh việc là con
bò khung bình để có thể kết nối được con
bò khung bình này với khu bình kia nó là
dựa chủ yếu là object detection và
object tracking phát hiện đối tượng và
theo dõi đối tượng
>> dạ Ừ
học về machining nó sẽ chán hơn rất
nhiều so với deing. Deing nó có mạng
neuron rồi bây gi ngôn ngữ lớn nó fancy
hơn rất là nhiều. Thế nhưng mà cái bảng
machining là cái bảng cung cấp kiến thức
nền tảng. Các bạn học chắc machining do
k học deing cực kỳ sướng luôn. Tại vì
diingink nó dùng rất nhiều lại dùng lại
rất nhiều kiến thức của machining.
Hành vi người làm gì nhá? Cũng có thể
dùng hành vi action recognition. Đúng
rồi.
Giờ trên hành vi thì bây giờ người ta sẽ
dùng cây mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn. Ví dụ đây
mình cho các bạn xem cái mô hình nạn
mình vừa tại vì bây giờ ấ cái mô hình
truyền thống thì các bạn có thể đánh
nhãn nhiều. Còn mô hình mà kiểu là dùng
mô hình ng lớn thì đây mình cho các bạn
xem thử nhá.
Cái gì nhỉ? Mình gọi là cái gì nhở? Ờ
này nhá.
Nhiều project quá không nhớ cái nào. Đây
đây kiểu không cái này cũng không cái
khác cơ.
Ờ đây ví dụ như ví dụ như như này đấy
như này đây. Đấy đúng không? Bình thường
bình thường là sẽ phải có có một cái có
có một cái mô hình phân loại mô hình
classification tức là các bạn cho cái
input là cái ảnh của một người của một
học sinh đúng và cái output nó phải có
nhãn thế nhưng mà làm vậy thì phải đánh
nhãn rượu rất là mất thời gian. Thì bây
giờ người ta dùng th mô hình ngôn ngữ
lớn để người ta có thể cái mô hình nó đã
hiểu về đã hiểu về về ngữ cảnh rồi thì
nó sẽ làm n thôi này thôi mình nói về
sau các bạn nhá. Thôi cái này đi xa quá
rồi. Đi xa quá rồi. Đây deep learning
rồi.
>> À mà anh ơi
>> ừ
>> ờ cái hòn anh nói là object detection
đúng không anh? Ừ đúng rồi.
>> Tức là nó chỉ khoanh nó chỉ nó chỉ gắn
cái barding box cho những cái con nào mà
nó là con bò thôi.
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Dạ thì em em em
nghĩ là cái ví dụ như là hồi trước em có
làm cái bài toán là animal
classification.
>> Ừ.
>> Tức là nó sẽ nhận diện đây là con chó,
đâu là con mèo.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì cái classification với lại cái
detection nó có khác nhau hay là nó
giống nhau không anh?
>> Có nhá. Khác nhau ở chỗ nào? Khác nhau ở
cái chỗ là đâu rồi? Bảo vào
nhở.
Đây nó khác nhau ở chỗ là như này. Với
bài toán object detection ấy thì input
của em là cả cái ảnh này và cái output
là nó sẽ phải chỉ ra là từng con bò nó ở
đâu và nó là con bò. Thì đây là bài toán
object detection. Thế còn cái in
classification là gì? Là em phải cắt
được cái hình con bò này ra. Em cho vào
mô hình classification và cái mô hình
classification nó lại chỉ chí ra là gì?
Đây là con bò. Thế thôi.
>> À
>> đấy thì đấy là cái sự khác biệt. Thông
thường ấy người ta sẽ làm thông thường
ấy người ta rất hay người ta sẽ kiểu là
người ta kẹp hai mô hình tức là gì? Đầu
tiên là objection để nó có thể nhận ví
dụ như này nhá. Ví dụ như là thường
thường người ta sẽ hay kẹp hai mô hình
với nhau. Kẹp tức là gì? Tức là object
decision đi trước.
Ờ object decision đi trước. Ví dụ nó nó
các bạn chờ tí nhá. Đằng nào cũng hết
giờ rồi các bạn nhá. Đằng nào cũng đ hết
giờ mình nói th ví dụ như này nhá. Ví dụ
mình có như này đây. Đây là cái mô hình
oxidation đi trước nó nhận input là cả
cái ảnh lớn này thì nó sẽ phải nhận diện
xem là cầu thủ nó ở đâu. Sau đó bây giờ
tôi muốn nhận diện cả số áo cầu thủ thì
tôi sẽ bắt đầu tôi sẽ crou tôi sẽ cắt
những cái ảnh này. Tôi cho vào một cái
mô hình thứ hai là mô hình
classification. Cái mô hình nó chỉ
classify là số áo từ 1 đến 20 chẳng hạn.
Ví dụ như vậy thì đấy cách kết hợp là
kẹp hai mô hình objection đi trước và
image classion đi sau. Nó trong
machining nó cũng hay người ta rất hay
kẹp. Ví dụ như vậy các bạn bảo ấy cái mô
hình đầu tiên là để phân loại cái gì sơ
sơ thẩm với cả phúc thẩm cái gì đấy nó
cũng kiểu kiểu như vậy đấy. Người ta rất
hay người ta kẹp các cái mô hình vào với
nhau. Cái mô hình sau nó sẽ làm một cái
task khác cho mô hình trước hoặc nó là
file tool tức là nó sẽ làm tốt hơn cái
kết quả của cái mô hình trước.
Rồi các bạn có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa
không?
Đ nhá. Hôm nay kiến thức hơi nặng đúng
không? Mai kiến thức nó sẽ nhẹ nhàng hơn
nhá. Phần mai nó nhẹ nhàng hơn đúng
không nhỉ?
Ừ phần mai
sẽ nhẹ nhàng hơn nhá. Mai nhẹ nhàng.
Last vision model là mô hình giống lag
language model là hình ngôn ngữ lớn tập
tập trung vào văn bản thì L vision model
là mô hình nó tập trung vào ảnh nó tập
trung vào ảnh mà thường bây giờ nó sẽ
dùng những cái mô hình người ta là
vision language model tức là mix cả text
với cả ảnh hoặc là multi model
tức là mô hình đa phương tiện. đáp phân
tiện tức là chơi cả tex cả ảnh cả audio
cả video.
Thế nhá thế nhá các bạn nhá. À mai mình
up cho các bạn solution của bài tập tuần
lớp mình thì có rất nhiều bạn làm được
bài tá chắc là lớp mình là cái lớp mà
làm được nhiều bài tá nhất trong tất cả
những lớp mình dạy từ trước đến giờ lớp
mình phải đến 20 bạn làm được rồi. Những
cái lớp trước thì loanh quanh có lớp nào
được năm bạn sáu bạn là nhiều. Lớp mình
rất là nhiều bạn rất là tốt. Trong khi
xin chỗ lớp mình lại không phải là lớp
nhiều quá nhiều so với những cái lớp
trước.
Mai mình sẽ up cho bạn solution nhá.
Solution mình sẽ up cho bạn bài tập mới.
Bài tập mới nó sẽ không khó bằng bài tập
tuần đầu đâu nhá. Mai mình sẽ up cho các
bạn nhá. Ok. Mai vẫn giờ này các bạn
nhá. Mai vẫn giờ này nhá.